ओके
या आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
अ
यस आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
चलिए अ ठीक है
जस्ट अ सेकंड
लेट मी इनफॉर्म
सभी को इनफॉर्म हम एक बार कर देते हैं।
ओके। सो वी आर लाइव राइट। हां जी। एम
ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल गाइस? क्लियर ऑडिबल एंड
विज़िबल? मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए।
प्लीज लेट मी नो। वंस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड
विज़िबल। क्लियरली। क्या बात है? 91 पीपल
आर हियर। [हंसी]
ओके
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट सो वी आर गोइंग टू
ब्रेक द रिकॉर्ड
1112 112
[हंसी]
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
ओके
वेरी गुड इवनिंग अ वेरी गुड इवनिंग
चलिए मुझे बता दीजिए ऑडियो में तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ना बिल्कुल भी प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है राइट सो दैट वी कैन स्टार्ट
ओके ग्रेट अह नो ठीक है क्लियर है चलिए
बहुत अच्छी बात है दैट्स ग्रेट दैट्स
ग्रेट
ओके सबसे पहले बिफोर वी स्टार्ट सबसे पहले
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप पे आ जाते हैं।
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप जो इस ट्रेनिंग के
लिए इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद के सर्टिफिकेशन के
लिए आपके लिए काफी जरूरी है। देखो सबसे
पहले मैं बताना चाहता हूं कि हमारी ये
ट्रेनिंग है एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल वन के
लिए। इसको मैं पूरा कवर करूंगा आपके लिए।
एंड मैं आपसे एक प्रॉमिस चाहता हूं आज
पहले ही क्लास में कि आप इस ट्रेनिंग को
सिंसियरली करेंगे। रेगुलर क्लासेस अटेंड
करेंगे। लाइव में आने की कोशिश करेंगे।
अगर आपके पास पॉसिबल हुआ आपके पास टाइम
हुआ तो लाइव ही अटेंड करेंगे। एंड वापस से
अगेन रिकॉर्डिंग देखेंगे ताकि आपका वो
क्लियर होता चले। क्योंकि एक बार सिर्फ
लाइव या सिर्फ रिकॉर्डिंग देख के कभी भी
कोई कॉन्सेप्ट बहुत डीप क्लियर नहीं होती।
आप एक्सपर्टीज नहीं बन सकते। ले ले नहीं
सकते। एक्सपर्टीज आपकी आएगी नहीं। तो लाइव
में आइए फिर आप जो है उसको स्टार्ट कीजिए।
अ आपके रिकॉर्डिंग को। सबसे पहला स्टेप
आपको करना है एज अ व्यूअर कि आपको हमारी
जो एसओसी एनालिस्ट की लाइव ट्रेनिंग की
अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो जो कल आई थी। राइट? आप
इस अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
इसको पॉज करते हैं। इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में
आपको जाना है एंड आपको दो चीजें करनी है।
पहला यह एक WhatsApp ग्रुप है जो कि एसओसी
के लिए स्पेशली हमने बनाया है। आपको इस
लिंक पे जाके इस WhatsApp ग्रुप को ज्वाइन
कर लेना है। इस ग्रुप को हम टाइम टू टाइम
ओपन करेंगे एंड आप वहां पे बाकी जो एसओसी
एंथोजियास्ट्स हैं उनके साथ इंटरेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। मैं खुद ग्रुप में कई बार
आऊंगा। आपके साथ बातें करूंगा एंड हम एक
दूसरे से इंटरेक्ट करेंगे। एंड आपकी जो भी
प्रॉब्लम्स है, क्वेरीज है, आप वहां डाल
सकते हैं जब भी ग्रुप ओपन होगी। ठीक है?
पहला काम यह करना है। दूसरा काम सेकंड एक
और लिंक होगी यहां पे। यह है WhatsApp
चैनल का लिंक जो कि डिफ्रानिस एकडमी नाम
से 10,000 से भी ज्यादा लोग जुड़े हैं
हमसे। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है। इसको
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि इस पे भी आपको
सारे अपडेट्स मिलेंगे। तो ये दोनों जगह पे
आपको आना ही आना है। ग्रुप एंड चैनल दोनों
पे आपको आके फॉलो करके ज्वाइन कर लेना है।
दैट्स इट। पहला स्टेप एंड सबसेेंट स्टेप
यही है। आप सभी को यह काम कर ही लेना है।
अगर पॉसिबल है तो मतलब मैंडेटरीली कर
लीजिएगा। चलिए।
ये काम हो गया। अब मैं यहां पे बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट मैं आता हूं एक ओहो 305 पीपल आर
हियर। गाइस इट्स अ रिकॉर्ड ब्रेकिंग 305
305 लोग यहां पे लाइव में आ चुके हैं
हमारे साथ फॉर एसओसी। दिस इज अमेजिंग। अभी
मैं यहां पर अपडेट डाल देता हूं। 300 प्लस
वाचिंग।
चलिए अच्छी बात है। मुझे अच्छा लगा ये देख
के कि अ आप में से काफी लोग काफी
एक्साइटेड हैं इस पर्टिकुलर अ जर्नी के
लिए एंड काफी इंटरेस्ट लेते हैं। तो आपके
लिए मैं अभी जो चीजें लेकर आऊंगा आपने कभी
सोचा नहीं होगा। एंड इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद
आप एलिजिबल हो जाएंगे एसओसी एल1 प्रोफाइल
के लिए। आप सर्टिफिकेशन हमारी करें ना
करें आप सर्टिफिकेट लें ना लें। स्टिल यू
विल गेन दोज़ स्किल्स दैट इज रिक्वायर्ड टू
बिकम एसओसी एल1 और ऐसी मुझे लगता है
YouTube हिस्ट्री में पहली बार होगी। मुझे
लगता है कि ऐसा शायद ही हुआ होगा कि एक
फ्री ट्रेनिंग आपके लिए ऐसी आएगी YouTube
पे वो भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी वो भी हिंदी के
अंदर हिंदी ऑडियंसेस के लिए कि आप उसको
करके एसओसी एल वन बन जाएंगे एंड आप वैसे
एल वन प्रोफाइल के जितने भी जॉब्स हैं
सबके लिए अप्लाई कर सकते हैं एंड हमारी
सर्टिफिकेट लगा भी सकते हैं नहीं भी
लगाएंगे तो आप उस लेवल के स्किल्स गेन कर
चुके होंगे कि इंटरव्यूअर कुछ भी पूछेगा
आपसे एल वन प्रोफाइल के लिए यू विल बी
आंसरिंग दैट हम इनफैक्ट इस ट्रेनिंग को एल
वन तो पूरा कवर करेंगे करेंगे। L2 के भी
कुछ बेसिक्स कवर जरूर करेंगे ताकि अगर
इंटरव्यूअर ने थोड़ा ट्रिक करने का कोशिश
किया आपको थोड़ी सी आप ट्रिकी क्वेश्चन
पूछ दिया, थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा एडवांस पूछ
दिया तो आपको वो भी नहीं छोड़ना है। वो भी
आपको आंसर करना है। उसका भी आपको जवाब
देना है। [हंसी] सो सो इट्स अ इट्स अ
काइंड ऑफ़ गेम चेंजर ट्रेनिंग जो आपके लिए
ये होने वाला है। याद रखिएगा। दिस विल बी
अ गेम चेंजर ट्रेनिंग। बस आपको थोड़ा मतलब
पेशेंस रखना है। थोड़ी इंटरेस्ट आपको शो
करनी है। मजा आना है। चलिए स्टार्ट करते
हैं। स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको बताना
चाहता हूं ये हमारी Lindin पेज है।
डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी की डिफ्रॉनिक
सर्च करेंगे। Lindin पे आप हमारे इस पेज
को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। सारे अपडेट्स कंपनी
स्टार्टअप हम किस तरीके से आगे क्या-क्या
ट्रेनिंग, फ्री कोर्सेस, पेड ट्रेनिंग्स
लेकर आने वाले हैं। सब आपको इस पे पता चल
जाएगी। साथ ही में यह मेरी प्रोफाइल है
Lindin पे। आप इस यूआरएल पे आके मेरी
प्रोफाइल को विजिट कर सकते हैं। मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं फॉर एनी काइंड ऑफ लाइक
टॉकिंग्स एंड कन्वर्सेशन या किसी भी तरह
की आप मेरे से जुड़ना चाहते हैं तो आप
मुझसे पर्सनली यहां से जुड़ सकते हैं।
बेसिकली मैं मोस्टली सबके इनवाइट्स
एक्सेप्ट कर लेता हूं। अभी तो कर ही लेता
हूं। यह हमारी वेबसाइट है। यहां पे आके
हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग अपडेट्स एंड ऑल
ये सारी चीजें आप देख सकते हैं। एकडमी पे
जाएंगे तो हमारा जो है यहां पे कोर्सर्सेस
लिस्ट होते हैं हमारे। इन कोर्सर्सेस को
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एंड वेरीफाई
योर सर्टिफिकेट्स पे हमारे यहां से अगर
आपने कोई भी सर्टिफिकेशन करी है पेड
सर्टिफिकेशन तो इसको यहां पे वेरिफिकेशन
आप कर सकते हैं। यह हमारा Twitter हैंडल
है जो कि है डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एंड डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल है। इस पे
आके आप हमारे Twitter पेज को फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। यहां पे हमारे Instagram पेज है
Instagram.com डेfronic accडमी हैंडल। आप
Instagram पेज को फॉलो कर सकते हैं। चलिए
यहां पे तो सारी कहानी हो चुकी है। एंड
मैंने आपको सारी चीजें अपडेट बता दी है।
अब आते हैं हमारे मेन एंड सबसे खतरनाक चीज
पे एंड दैट इज हमारी एसओसी
जो कि एक अ यू कैन से कि एक एल1 रोल के
लिए हमारी ये पूरी ट्रेनिंग है। एंड इसको
हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। अब इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग
में मैं आपसे एक प्रॉमिस चाहता हूं जो कि
आप चैट में बता सकते हैं। ऑल ट्रेनिंग्स
जितने भी यहां पे आप लोग प्रेजेंट हैं तो
उन सब से पूछना चाहता हूं। उन सब से एक एक
बस प्रॉमिस चाहता हूं मैं कि आप सब लाइव
अटेंड करेंगे। अभी आप 300 से भी ज्यादा
लोग जुड़े हुए हैं मेरे साथ आज फर्स्ट
सेशन में। क्या आप 300 टोटल 300 लोग ये
प्रॉमिस करते हैं कि आप हर लाइव सेशन को
एटलीस्ट कोशिश करेंगे अपना 100% ट्राई
करेंगे अटेंड करने का। मुझे प्रॉमिस कर दो
ताकि देखो प्रॉमिस मैं इसलिए करवा रहा हूं
मेरा कुछ नहीं जा रहा। आप लाइव नहीं अटेंड
करेंगे कुछ नहीं। मैं तो अपना डिलीवर
करूंगा ही। बट लाइव में जब आप आते हो ना
तो मेरे को जब ये देखता हूं ना मैं कि आप
लाइव में आए हो तो मुझे भी काफी इंटरेस्ट
आता है। काफी मजा आता है। एक अमेजिंग
फीलिंग आती है। तो वो इसलिए मैं आपसे बोल
रहा हूं कि अगर आप लाइव में आते हो ना तो
एक अलग एक अलग माहौल बनता है। राइट? तो वो
माहौल बनाने आओगे कि नहीं आओगे? पहले ये
बताओ। प्रॉमिस कर रहे हो?
यस। मैं देख रहा हूं काफी लोग काफी लोग
यहां पे मैसेज कर रहे हैं। विल ट्राई माय
बेस्ट। ग्रेट ग्रेट। वाओ ग्रेट
बहुत बढ़िया थैंक्स थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर
प्रॉमिसिंग मी एंड आई होप कि यू विल
फुलफिल योर प्रॉमिस मेरे से तो प्रॉमिस
फुलफिल आप करवा लेते हो मैं कर देता हूं
बट आप भी करोगे अब इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग को
आपको किस तरीके से आगे बढ़ाना है मैं सब
बताऊंगा क्या-क्या चीजें हम कवर करने वाले
हैं मैं सब बताऊंगा एंड कैसे हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे कैसे हम एक एल1 लेवल तक पहुंचेंगे
एक फ्री ट्रेनिंग के अंदर क्वालिटी किस
तरीके से आपको मिलेगी सब चीजें हम डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं मेरे साथ। बस सीट बेल्ट को
टाइट कर लीजिए एंड वी आर गोइंग फॉर द टेक
ऑफ। ओके? सो दिस इज़ आवर फ्रॉम जीरो टू
एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल वन कंप्लीट ट्रेनिंग
प्रोग्राम प्लस सर्टिफिकेशन। अ यहां पे
सिंपल सी बात है। यू विल लर्न टू यहां पे
मैं हाईलाइट अ पॉइंटर कर देता हूं। यू विल
लर्न टू थिंक लाइक अ सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल
एनालाइज थ्रेट्स विथ प्रिसाइजन एंड
अंडरस्टैंड द रियल वर्ल्ड एसओसी
एनवायरमेंट वेयर साइबर डिफेंडर्स
प्रोटेक्ट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन 24 * 7 नो प्रायर
एक्सपीरियंस इज़ नीडेड जस्ट कमिटमेंट्स टू
मास्टर द स्किल्स दैट मैटर्स। कोई भी
प्रायर आपको एक्सपीरियंस की जरूरत नहीं
है। आप क्या करेंगे? आप सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल की तरह थिंक करने लगेंगे। आप
थ्रेट्स को एनालाइज़ करेंगे। बहुत ही
प्रिसाइज़न के साथ। आप रियल वर्ल्ड एसोसिए
एनवायरमेंट के अंदर अपने आप को काम करने
के लायक समझने लगेंगे एंड एक डिफेंडर की
तरह काम करेंगे इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद इस
लेवल की ये ट्रेनिंग आपकी होने वाली है।
नाउ सबसे पहले व्हाई एसओसी एग्जिस्ट्स एंड
द डिजिटल बैटल फील्ड इन सबके पहले मैं
आपको एक चीज दिखाना चाहता हूं कि हाउ वी
आर गोइंग टू अप्रोच दिस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग। मैं क्यों दिखा रहा हूं मैं
आपको बताता हूं। अब मैं Lindin पे जा रहा
हूं। मैं Lindin पे एक सर्च करता हूं चीज
एंड सर्च करता हूं एसओसी एल1। ठीक है? मैं
ये Lindin पे सर्च कर रहा हूं। आप भी सर्च
कर सकते हैं। अब Socl1 जब सर्च करेंगे,
जॉब्स पेज पे जाएंगे तो आपको एसओसी एल1 के
इतने सारे अ रिक्रूटमेंट्स मिलेंगे ना,
इतने सारे रिक्रूटमेंट्स मिलेंगे। यू कैन
नॉट इमेजिन इवन। बाकी रोल्स के लिए
रिक्रूटमेंट्स इतने ज्यादा आपको नहीं
दिखेंगे Lindin पे। पे बट एसओसी के लिए
बहुत ज्यादा दिखते हैं। क्यों? एसओसी अपने
आप में एक टीम होती है। कई कंपनीज़ एसओसी
इवन गवर्नमेंट का एक रूल है। यू कैन से कि
एक स्टैंडर्ड उन्होंने सेट किया है कि हर
एंटरप्राइज को एक एसओसी टीम रखनी ही रखनी
है। ताकि किसी भी तरह के बड़े अटैक, बड़े
इवेंट्स को वो कैटर कर पाए। वो काउंटर
मेजर कर पाए। इस वजह से एसओसी की
रिक्वायरमेंट बढ़ जाती है। एंड साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर अगर आप एक बिगिनर हैं।
ठीक है? आपको कुछ नहीं पता। यू आर अ
एब्सोल्यूट बिगिनर एंड आपको घुसना है ना
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में तो एसओसी के थ्रू
घुसना सबसे इजी एंड सबसे ज्यादा इफेक्टिव
अप्रोच माना जाता है। एंड इसलिए मैंने
सोचा कि इसकी ट्रेनिंग लेकर आते हैं। अब
मान लो मेरे पास एक एसएस एस एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल वन की प्रोफाइल के लिए यहां
पे अप्लाई करने का ऑप्शन है। ठीक है? अब
मैं यहां पे अप्लाई करके अप्लाई कर दूंगा
और नीचे जब आऊंगा तो इसके पूरी डिटेल्स
लिखी जाएंगी कि एक्जेक्टली क्या-क्या आपको
रिक्वायरमेंट है इस रोल के लिए। अब मैंने
इसी अप्लाई वाले टैब को एक नया टैब में
यहां पे ओपन किया है। इन्हीं का एंटीटी
डाटा का इनकी जो रिक्वायरमेंट है। अब मैं
यह रिक्वायरमेंट क्यों दिखा रहा हूं यह
आपके लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो देखिएगा
मैं एक-एक बात जो बोलूंगा आज के सेशन में
वो आपके लिए एक-एक चीज बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
होने वाली है। इस बात को ध्यान रखिएगा।
ठीक है?
थैंक यू फॉर प्रॉमिसिंग। अभी तक यू आर
प्रॉमिसिंग। अभी तक प्रॉमिससेस मिल रहे
हैं मुझे। आई होप कि आप इस प्रॉमिस को
फुलफिल करेंगे। अगर आप फुलफिल नहीं करेंगे
तो आपकी वो गलती होगी। आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। अगर फुलफिल करेंगे तो
मुझसे ज्यादा हैप्पी इंसान कोई नहीं हो
सकता। कौन इतना करता है भाई कि आपको
जबरदस्ती बुलवाए लाइफ में। प्रॉमिस करवाए
लाइफ में क्या हो? किसी को कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ता। आप आते हो तो मुझे मजा आता है। बस
इतना ही मुझे पता है। अब देखो यहां पे
अब मैंने ये जॉब रोल इसलिए खोला। अब इस
जॉब रोल में जब आप आओगे तो यहां पे इनका
एक रिक्वायर्ड एक्सपीरियंस है। ठीक है? अब
मैंने यह इसलिए ओपन किया है क्योंकि मैं
इस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग का जो सिलेबस मैंने
डिजाइन करा है जो सिलेबस मैं आपके सामने अ
डिलीवर करने वाला हूं पूरी ट्रेनिंग के
थ्रू वो मैं नॉर्मल एक नॉर्मल सिलेबस आपके
सामने नहीं ला के रखूंगा कि कहीं से कुछ
उठाया सिलेबस उठा के आपको दे दिया कि भैया
ये टॉपिक है ये टॉपिक है मैं पढ़ा दूंगा
खत्म हो गया एसओसी एनालिस्ट है एल1 नहीं
मैंने क्या किया है जितने भी एसओसी एल1 के
रोल्स होते हैं जिसके लिए जॉब्स
रिक्वायरमेंट जो जॉब रिक्वायरमेंट जॉब
रोल्स होती है जेडी जिसको आप बोलते हैं
जॉब डिस्क्रिप्शन जिसको बोलते हैं मैंने
ऐसे मल्टीपल रोल्स मल्टीपल रिक्वायरमेंट्स
को उठाया है उनमें से जोज रिक्वायरमेंट्स
हैं और जो जोज आपके की रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज
हैं उनको उठाया है और उनमें जो जोज
स्किल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट होगी जो जो चीजें
चाहिए होंगी उन सबको इंक्लूड कर दिया है
एंड वो सारी चीजें मैं आपको सिखाने वाला
हूं तो इसका मतलब है आप पूरी पूरी तरीके
से एक जॉब ओरिएंटेड टाइप ट्रेनिंग को कर
रहे होंगे इस पर्टिकुलर एसओसी एनालिस्ट
ट्रेनिंग के थ्रू। समझ में आ रहा है मैं
क्या कहना चाह रहा हूं? आर यू गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट्स व्हाट आई एम ट्राइंग टू से टू यू
एवरीबॉडी प्लीज लेट मी नो। आर यू गेटिंग
माय पॉइंट्स कि मैं किस लेवल की बात कर
रहा हूं? मैं एक नॉर्मल कन्वेंशनल सिलेबस
की बात नहीं कर रहा। मैं कोई छोटी-मोटी
सिलेबस की बात नहीं कर रहा। मैं बात कर
रहा हूं एक जॉब में जो रिक्वायरमेंट चाहिए
कंपनीज़ को जो इंडस्ट्री को चाहिए जो जो
चीजें ये यहां पे मांगते हैं ना स्क्रीन
पे वही चीजें आपको डिलीवर करूंगा वही
चीजें आपको देने की पूरी कोशिश करूंगा इस
पूरी ट्रेनिंग में सो यू मस्ट बी गेटिंग
दिस राइट
राइट अब ये जो अह अब ये जो
हां अब ये जो चीजें हैं लाइक ये जो पूरी
की पूरी ट्रेनिंग है इस ट्रेनिंग के अंदर
मैं आपको एक चीज़ बता देता हूं। मैं एक चीज़
समझा देता हूं। इस पूरी की पूरी ट्रेनिंग
के अंदर में। हां जी। थैंक्स। थैंक्स। अ
[हंसी]
थैंक यू। थैंक यू। इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग के
अंदर में आपको जो सिलेबस मिलने वाली है वो
बहुत हटके मिलने वाली है। तो आप इमेजिन
नहीं कर सकते हैं। बट मुझ मैं मैं आपसे एक
ही चीज चाहता हूं। मैं बस आपसे एक चीज़
चाहता हूं कि एक WhatsApp ग्रुप और
WhatsApp चैनल उसको ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
WhatsApp ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक मिल जाएगी।
WhatsApp चैनल पे जाके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक मिल जाएगी। एंड जो
भी आपको इस पूरे ट्रेनिंग में सिखाया
जाएगा, जो भी इस ट्रेनिंग में आपको पर
क्लासेस में बताऊंगा मैं समझाऊंगा मैं
उसके की पॉइंट्स जब आप लाइव को अटेंड करके
रिकॉर्डिंग देखेंगे तो की पॉइंट्स को नोट
करेंगे और उन की पॉइंट्स को आप Lindin पे
आके Lindin पे आप आएंगे, पोस्ट करेंगे और
हमें टैग कर देंगे। डिफ्रानी को टैग कर
देंगे। बस इतना करेंगे एंड दैट्स इट। अब
आते हैं यहां पर रिस्पांसिबिलिटी के ऊपर
में।
अब देखो यहां पे है पर्सन शुड हैव
एडिक्वेट नॉलेज ऑफ सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस
लाइक फायरवल्स आईपीएस वेब एप्लीकेशन
फायरवल डीडीओएस ईडीआर इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस
एसओएआर एंड सोर जिसको बहुत लोग सोर बोलते
हैं एसओआर एंड अदर सिक्योरिटी डिवाइसेस तो
ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं फायरवॉल्स आईपीएस वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायर वाल्स डीडीओएस ईडीआर
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस रिलेटेड चीजें ये सब हम
इसमें कवर करेंगे उसके बाद कंस्ट्रक्शन ऑफ
एसआईएम कंटेंट रिक्वायर्ड टू प्रोड्यूस
कंटेंट आउटपुट्स लाइक फ़िल्टर्स, एक्टिव
लिस्ट, कोरिलेशन रूल्स, रिपोर्ट्स,
रिपोर्ट टेंपल्लेट्स, क्वरीज़, ट्रेंड्स,
वेरिएबल्स इन सबको हम कवर करेंगे। एसआईएम
को हम कवर करेंगे। नॉलेज ऑफ़ पैकेट लेवल
एनालिसिस। हम पैकेट लेवल एनालिसिस करेंगे।
एनालिसिस टूल्स का यूज़ करेंगे। पिकअप
फाइल्स वगैरह को देखेंगे। सब चीजें
करेंगे। नॉलेज ऑफ़ नेटवर्किंग प्रोटोकॉल्स
एंड टेक्नोलॉजीस एंड नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी।
हम नॉलेज लेंगे नेटवर्किंग प्रोटोकॉल्स
का। नेटवर्किंग टेक्नोलॉजीस एंड नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी का। साउंड एनालिटिकल एंड ट्रबल
शूटिंग स्किल्स। कैसे एनालिटिकल अ
एनालिटिकल स्किल्स को डेवलप करके ट्रबल
शूटिंग स्किल्स आप डेवलप कर सकते हैं वो
सब चीजें सीखेंगे। तो अगर मैं बात करूं इस
रोल के लिए तो इस रोल के रिक्वायर्ड
एक्सपीरियंस के एंड जो भी टॉपिक्स है वो
तो वो तो पूरा कर लिया हमने। वी कंप्लीटेड
इट। अभी बातों में किया है। क्लास में कर
लेंगे बट कंप्लीट तो कर लिया। बट वी
कंप्लीटेड राइट वी कंप्लीटेड। एक सेकंड
वी कंप्लीटेड। तो मैं इसको कवर कर दिया
मैं। मैं कवर करूंगा तो हो गई ना ये चीज।
अब देखो की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी के ऊपर आ जाते
हैं। की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज
के ऊपर आ जाते हैं। अच्छा कुछ लोग पूछ रहे
हैं कि सर ये कितने टाइम तक क्लासेस
चलेंगी? अच्छा आपको क्या लगता है पूरी
एसओसी एल1 को कवर करने में लगभग कितना
टाइम लग जाता है? लगभग कितना टाइम लगना
चाहिए? आपको क्या लगता है? व्हाट डू थिंक?
अगर हम वीक में दो तीन क्लासेस लेकर आते
हैं तो आपको क्या लगता है? हाउ मच टाइम इट
कैन टेक? टू कंप्लीट द एल1 ट्रेनिंग्स।
ओके। एक मंथ एक कोई बोल रहा है वन मंथ।
कोई बोल रहा है 2 मंथ। कोई बोल रहा है
सिक्स मंथ्स। ठीक है? सो मैं आपको इसका एक
अप्रोक्स टाइम बता देता हूं। ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग्स को कंप्लीट करने में कम से कम
3 महीने तो लगेंगे। कम से कम 3 मंथ्स
लगेंगे लगेंगे। क्योंकि ये एक बहुत ब्रॉड
कैटेगरी ऑफ़ स्किल है जो इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में। और याद रखिएगा ये साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का ही एक डोमेन है एसओसी। एंड
ये ब्लू टीमिंग के अंदर आता है। आप ब्लू
टीमर बन जाएंगे। यू विल बेसिकली यू आर
प्रिपेयरिंग फॉर ब्लू टीम। ये ब्लू टीम का
ही पार्ट है भाई। ब्लू टीम का बहुत बड़ा
पार्ट है। इनफैक्ट तो आप लोग पूछ रहे थे
ना कि सर सब रेड टीमिंग रेड टीमिंग कराते
हैं। आपकी वीएपीटी ट्रेनिंग जो है
डीसीएपीटी वो भी रेड टीमिंग पे बेस्ड है
मोस्टली। तो ब्लू टीमिंग का क्या? तो आ गई
ब्लू टीम भाई। इट्स ब्लू टीम। आ जाओ ब्लू
टीम करो ब्लू टीम। तो ब्लू टीमिंग के आप
पार्ट हो जाओगे। एंड ब्लू टीमिंग पूरी आप
अगर कंप्लीट करते हो एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए
तो थोड़ा टाइम तो लगेगा। सो इट्स काइंड ऑफ
एटलीस्ट थ्री मंथ्स लगेगा। थोड़ा बहुत ऊपर
नीचे हो सकता है बट एटलीस्ट थ्री मंथ्स आप
मान के चलिए। एंड टाइमिंग जो होगी मोस्टली
जब भी क्लासेस होंगी वो 7:00 pm के आसपास
ही होंगी। 7:00 pm मोस्टली होंगी आपकी
क्लासेस। ठीक है? सही है? मजा आ गया?
अब एक चीज आपसे पूछना चाहता हूं। प्लीज
बताइए मुझे क्योंकि आप में से कई लोग इस
पे बात करते हैं कि पर क्लासेस की
ड्यूरेशन आप क्या चाहते हैं? बहुत लंबा
चाहते हैं या मिड रेंज की 1 घंटे की चाहते
हैं या 1 घंटे से ऊपर की चाहते हैं?
क्योंकि कई लोग कंप्लेन करते थे कि भैया
बहुत लंबा मत रखो क्योंकि रिकॉर्डिंग
देखते टाइम हम बोर हो जाते हैं। थोड़ा सा
मतलब थोड़ा अजीब लगता है। छोटे-छोटे रहते
हैं तो हम जल्दी-जल्दी एक-एक खत्म कर
दिया। एक पार्ट ये हो गई तो मजा आता है।
तो मुझे आप बताइए कि क्या चाहते हैं आप?
बेसिकली ड्यूरेशन क्या चाहते हैं? 1 आवर
टू 1.5 आवर्स 2 आवर्स 3 आवर्स वन ऑवर वन
ऑवर वन ऑवर के फेवर में काफी लोग हैं। वन
एंड 1.5 आवर। ठीक है? चलिए तो हम वन एंड
1.5 आवर के बीच की रखेंगे पर सेशन को।
बहुत ज्यादा लंबा नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि आप
में से भी मैक्सिमम लोग यही चाहते हैं। सो
दैट कि आप छोटे-छोटे टुकड़ों में जब पढ़ते
हैं ना तो आप ज्यादा गैब करते हैं और आपको
ज्यादा मजा आता है। तो यू विल लव इट।
राइट? चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज के ऊपर में। मॉनिटर्स
क्लाइंट इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एंड सॉल्यूशन।
मैं ये इसलिए आपको बता रहा हूं क्योंकि
इससे आपको एक ओवरव्यू मिल जाएगा कि एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आप करते क्या हैं? एंड
याद रखिएगा एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट बिकमिंग
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट इज़ अ पार्ट ऑफ़ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी जर्नी। तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी से
ही कनेक्टेड है। ब्लू टीमिंग आप कर रहे
हैं। यू विल बी बिकम यू विल बिकम अ ब्लू
टीमर। एल1 जूनियर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट के
रोल पे आता है। जूनियर रोल में रहते हैं।
ठीक है? एज अ फ्रेशर बहुत अच्छा एक
अपॉर्चुनिटी मिलता है। मॉनिटर्स क्लाइंट
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एंड सॉलशंस। आप क्लाइंट
के इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सॉलशंस को मॉनिटर करते
हैं। आपकी रेस्पोंसिबिलिटी में आती है।
आइडेंटिफाई प्रॉब्लम्स एंड एरर्स प्रायर
टू और व्हेन दे अकर मतलब अभी कोई प्रॉब्लम
आने वाली है। उसके पहले ही आप उसको
आइडेंटिफाई करने की कोशिश करेंगे एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट। रूटीनली आइडेंटिफाई
कॉमन इंसिडेंट्स एंड ओपोरर्चुनिटीज़ फॉर
अवॉयडेंस एज वेल एज जनरल ओपोरर्चुनिटीज़
फॉर इंसिडेंट रिडक्शन। मतलब कि आप रूटीन
रूटीन वाइज आप कॉमन इंसिडेंट्स को
आइडेंटिफाई करेंगे एंड कोशिश करेंगे कि
किसी भी तरह का जो अटैक है उससे बचा जा
सके। इन्वेस्टिगेट्स फर्स्ट लाइन
इंसिडेंट्स असाइन एंड आइडेंटिफाई अ रूट
कॉज ऑफ इंसिडेंट एंड प्रॉब्लम्स। कोई भी
इंसिडेंट हुआ है, कोई अटैक हुआ है, किसी
तरह का, किसी भी तरह का अटैक हुआ है, तो
उसका रूट कॉज क्या है? उसको आइडेंटिफाई
करना आपका काम होगा। प्रोवाइड्स टेलीफ़ोनिक
और चैट सपोर्ट टू क्लाइंट्स व्हेन
रिक्वायर्ड। टेलीफोनिक मतलब हाय हेलो कैसे
हो कैसे हो वो वाला प्यार मोहब्बत वाली
टेलीफोनिक यहां बात नहीं करनी है आपको
क्लाइंट से आपको बात करनी है सिक्योरिटी
थ्रेट्स के रिगार्डिंग कि भैया देखो इस
तरीके की चीजें हमने फाइंड की है इस तरह
के अटैक हुए हमने ये पैटर्न नोटिस किया है
हमने ये इंसिडेंट का रूट कॉज फाइंड किया
है एंड उनको बताना है उनको गाइड करना है
उनको थोड़ा सा असिस्ट करना है ये वाली
टेलीफोनिक समझे
शेड्यूल्स मेंटेनेंस एक्टिविटी विंडज़ फॉर
पैचिंग एंड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंजेस मतलब कि
एक्टिविटी मेंटेन एक्टिविटी विंडो मेंटेन
करनी है किसके लिए? पैचिंग के लिए। मतलब
पैच करना किस तरीके से क्या कर पैचिंग
करना है आपको? उसको रिॉल्व करना है इन सब
चीजों के लिए आप एक एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
बनेंगे। फॉलोस द रिक्वायर्ड हैंड ओवर
प्रोसीजर। पूरा एक प्रोसीजर फॉलो करना है
आपको। रिपोर्ट्स एंड एस्केलेट्स
इंसिडेंट्स वेयर नेसेसरी। अब ये एस्केलेट
किसको करना है भैया? तो आप एज अ L1 जब
होंगे तो आप L2 को एस्केलेट करेंगे। L3 को
एस्केलेट करेंगे। L2, L3 फिर इंजीनियर एंड
मल्टीपल मैनेजर मल्टीपल फिर आगे जो है
रोल्स आते हैं जो आपके सीनियर्स कहलाते
हैं। उन सीनियर्स के पास आप एस्केलेट करते
हैं। ठीक है? इंश्योर द एफिशिएंट एंड
कॉम्प्रिहेंसिव रेोल्यूशन ऑफ इंसिडेंट्स
एंड रिक्वेस्ट। अब इसका रेोल्यूशन भी आप
ही को मतलब बनाना है कि भैया किस लेवल की
पहले तो किस लेवल का अटैक है। अगर बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स एंड हायर्ड अटैक है तो आपको
फॉरवर्ड कर देना है। नहीं तो आपको फिर
वहीं पे एक रिपोर्ट बनानी है, तैयार करना
है एंड बताना है कि भैया क्या दिक्कत है?
किस तरह की प्रॉब्लम्स हुई है, क्या इशूज़
हुए हैं वो सारी चीजें। अपडेट्स एकिस्टिंग
नॉलेज आर्टिकल्स और क्रिएट न्यू वंस। मतलब
कि आपको आप कुछ उस पर्टिकुलर अटैक पैटर्न
के रिगार्डिंग एक आर्टिकल अगर कोई ऑलरेडी
है तो उसको अपडेट कर दीजिए कि हां भैया
मैंने ये चीजें नई चीजें नोटिस करी है
इसमें या एक नया आर्टिकल लिख दीजिए ताकि
लोगों को उससे हेल्प मिले लोग उससे
कोस्पोंड कर पाएं। आइडेंटिफाई
ओपोरर्चुनिटीज़ फॉर वर्क ऑप्टिमाइजेशन
इंक्लूडिंग अपोरर्चुनिटीज़ फॉर ऑटोमेशन ऑफ़
वर्क। अब ये चीजें इन्होंने कुछ की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज में कुछ एक्स्ट्रा भी ऐड
करा है। बट ये सब चीजें कवर हो जाती हैं
ऑटोमेटिकली जब आप वो स्किल्स गेन कर लेते
हैं। मे आल्सो कंट्रीब्यूट सपोर्ट ऑन
प्रोजेक्ट वर्क एज और व्हेन रिक्वायर्ड कि
ये तो कंपनी की अपनी रिक्वायरमेंट है। मे
वर्क ऑन इंप्लीमेंटिंग एंड डिलीवरिंग
डिजास्टर रिकवरी फंक्शनंस एंड डिजास्टर
रिकवरी फंक्शनंस को इंप्लीमेंट करना
डिलीवर करना। जैसे मान लो रसवेयर अटैक हो
जाता है किसी कंपनी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
ऊपर। बहुत बड़ा अटैक हो जाता है। उस केस
में फिर डिजास्टर रिकवरी फंक्शनंस को
एग्जीक्यूट करना बहुत जरूरी हो जाती है।
परफॉर्म्स एनी अदर रिलेटेड टास्क मतलब कोई
भी हम देंगे तो वो करना पड़ेगा। तो अब
यहां पे गाइज़ इनकी जो रिक्वायरमेंट्स है
ये कोई बहुत बड़ा मेजर रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है। आपने ये जो चीजें सीख ली ना ये जो
इनको चाहिए बस हो गया खत्म। यू आर रेडी।
यू आर रेडी टू अप्लाई। यही तो चाहिए भैया।
मैं सब सिखा के रहूंगा। मैं गारंटी दे रहा
हूं तुम्हें। गारंटी के साथ दे रहा हूं।
कहीं कोई कोर्स मैं इस बात की गारंटी अभी
दे दे रहा हूं। इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद एल1
प्रोफाइल के लिए किसी भी ट्रेनिंग कोर्स
करने की आपको जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी। कहीं पे
भी कोई पेड ट्रेनिंग नहीं करनी है। एल1 के
लिए स्पेशली एल1 के लिए नहीं करनी पड़ेगी।
क्योंकि आप रेडी हो जाओगे ना क्योंकि अगर
ट्रेनिंग हम दे रहे हैं और अगर हम पूरी
कंप्लीट डीप इनसाइड घुस के नहीं दे रहे
हैं तब तो हम बेवकूफ बना रहे हैं आपको ना।
सीधी सी बात है। और वो काम डिफ्रॉनिक्स
नहीं करती है और मैं कभी ऐसा होने भी नहीं
दूंगा। अगर कोई और भी करना बाय चांस कोई
अगर करे तो आई विल नॉट लेट दैट हैपन। एंड
मैं खुद तो कभी जिंदगी में आज तक मैंने
कभी करा नहीं है और ना डिफ्रॉनिक्स के
साइड से यह होने दूंगा। तो आप उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिएगा। आप प्राउडली बोलिएगा कि
हां डिफ्रॉनिक्स एक चैनल है। एक YouTube
चैनल है बस जहां पे हमें एक कंटेंट मिलता
है क्वालिटी वाली एंड एक ऐसी कंटेंट मिलती
है जिस पे हम आंख बंद करके बिलीव कर सकते
हैं। ट्रस्ट कर सकते हैं। और अब तो ये जॉब
रिलेटेड जॉब ओरिएंटेड और जॉब रेडी चीजें
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं फ्री में। तो बस आपका
सपोर्ट चाहिए और कुछ नहीं चाहिए। सपोर्ट
की जब मैं बात करता हूं मैं बात करता हूं
कि आप वीडियोस को शेयर करें अपने जितने भी
लोग ऐसे देखो नॉलेज को जितना शेयर करोगे
उतना बढ़ेगा। आप सोच रहे हो नॉलेज अपने तक
रख के मैं लोगों को नहीं बताऊंगा कि हां
फ्री में ट्रेनिंग चल रही है तो ये आपकी
नॉलेज को कैप कर देगा। आपकी नॉलेज को
श्रिंक कर देगा। वो छोटा हो जाएगा आपका
नॉलेज। आपका नॉलेज फिर ना वो एक्सपैंड
नहीं करेगा। बट आप शेयर करोगे ना दूसरों
से दूसरों को बताओगे सिखाओगे तो आपकी
नॉलेज ऑटोमेटिकली एक्सपैंड होगी और उसका
कोई जो है ना कंपैरिजन नहीं है। तो आप
लोगों के बीच शेयर भी जरूर कीजिएगा ताकि
उनको पता चले इस ट्रेनिंग के बारे में सब
जगह फैला दीजिए एंड बिल्कुल जहां भी शेयर
कीजिए अगर हमें टैग कर सकते हैं तो
बिल्कुल कीजिएगा। वी विल बी ग्लैड एंड वी
विल बी मोर देन हैप्पी। चलिए अब आपको पूरा
का पूरा ये समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट? अह
इस पूरा यह सिनेरियो समझ में आ गया कि
एक्सैक्टली हम क्या-क्या चीजें करने वाले
हैं। राइट? अब हम आते हैं यहां पे एक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज पे एक वेब अ पेज पे जो कि
मैंने आपके लिए यहां पे वेब पेज डेवलप करा
है। हम इस पे आ जाते हैं। ठीक है? अब इस
वेब पेज पे जब आप आएंगे तो आपको कुछ चीजें
दिखेंगी। मैं इसको बाहर निकाल देता हूं
ताकि यह सिर्फ सिंगल ऑन दिखे आपको। राइट?
सो, नाउ इट्स विज़िबल। सबसे पहले देखो
एसओसी के लिए एसओसी रोल के लिए जब आप
जाओगे एसओसी के लिए काम करने जाओगे पता है
तो कुछ-कुछ टूल कुछ-कुछ टेक्नोलॉजीस आपके
काम आती है एसआईएम
ठीक है ये एक आपका एक सॉफ्टवेयर बोलो एक
टेक्नोलॉजी बोलो यह एसआईएम इसका आपको नाम
सुनने को काफी मिलेगा स्प्लक इसका आपको
नाम काफी सुनने को मिलेगा स्प्लंक इज़
आल्सो अह सॉफ्टवेयर तो इन चीजों पे आपको
काम करना ही करना है क्योंकि यह
एंटरप्राइज लेवल पे यूज़ होते हैं और इसके
बिना एसओसी ऑपरेट नहीं कर सकती है।
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन ऑपरेशन सेंटर जो है ये
एसओसी एनालिस्ट इसके बिना इनके नॉलेज के
बिना ऑपरेट नहीं कर सकते हैं। ऐसे ऐसे
बहुत सारे और भी टूल्स हैं। वी विल बी
सीइंग दोज़ टूल्स आल्सो हम उनको भी
देखेंगे। बट यह आपको बार-बार मिलेंगे।
आपको देखने को मिलेंगे। बट बिफोर दैट
बिफोर
मैं यहां पर दोज टूल्स बिफोर यू टच एसआईएम
यू मस्ट अंडरस्टैंड द बैटल फील्ड। आपको
बैटल फील्ड समझना है पहले। द एसओसी इज़ द
सेंट्रल नर्वस सिस्टम ऑफ एन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस डिफेंस। एसओसी जो है वो एक
नर्वस सिस्टम है। ऑर्गेनाइजेशन किसी भी
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के डिफेंस का। आप
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस होते हैं। मतलब
किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेटवर्क के ऊपर चाहे
वो किसी भी कंपनी के ऊपर अटैक जब होता है
ना तो उसका पहला जो फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस
होता है जो पहले डिफेंडर्स होते हैं वो
एसोसिस एनालिस्ट होते हैं। कितना मजा आ
रहा है सुन के। कितना अमेजिंग लग रहा है
कि हम फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस होंगे। हमारे
ऊपर डिपेंड करता है कंपनी की बैंड बजेगी
या कंपनी बच जाएगा। कंपनी के डाटा डार्क
वेब पे सेल होंगे कि नहीं होंगे। सब हम पे
डिपेंड करता है। हमारे एक्सीलेंस पे
डिपेंड करता है। हमारे टैलेंट, हमारे
स्किल्स पे डिपेंड करता है। सोचो कितनी
बड़ी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। तो उसके लिए
आपको थोड़ा डीप घुसना ही पड़ेगा। थोड़ा
अपने पेशेंस को बना के रखना होगा और थोड़ा
मतलब
मतलब पागलों जैसे सीखना होगा। पागलों पागल
बनना पड़ेगा आपको इसकी स्किल्स को सर
सीखने के लिए। तो मेरे साथ आप भी पागल बन
जाइए। सिंपल सी बात है। मैं पागल बन के
पढ़ाऊंगा। पागल बन के पढ़ लीजिएगा। यही तो
होगा। एंड फिर बेस्ट रिजल्ट मिल जाएगा
आपको। इससे ज्यादा क्या बोलूंगा मैं?
ठीक है।
चलिए,
जैसे मैं करा रहा हूं, वैसे आप कीजिए।
चलिए, अब यहां पे आ जाते हैं। व्हाई एसओसी
एक्जिस्ट? पहली बात है एसओसी एक्सिस्ट
करता क्यों है? ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस जो होते हैं
ब्लीड डाटा एंड मनी। डाटा और मनी ब्लीड
करते हैं। डाटा लॉस डाटा सेलिंग होती है
उनके। पैसे देते हैं रसमवेयर को। रेंसवेर
अटैक हो जाता है। पैसे भरते रहते हैं। द
एसओसी एक्सिस्ट टू मिनिमाइज डीवेल टाइम
ड्वेल टाइम जो बोलते हैं आप उसको द टाइम
एंड अटैकर स्टेज हिडन। तो एसओसीस का सबसे
मेन मकसद और फंक्शन होता है कि डुएल टाइम
डी टाइम जिसको आप बोल सकते हैं उसको
मिनिमाइज करना। डीएल टाइम क्या होता है?
डुअल टाइम क्या होता है आपका? द टाइम एंड
अटैकर स्टेज़ हिडन। मतलब एक अटैकर नेटवर्क
के अंदर में कितने देर तक
कितने देर तक जॉइन मतलब हाइड करके रह रहा
है उसको बोलते हैं डीवेल।
ठीक है? प्लीज यहां पे आप स्पैम मत कीजिए
आप लोग। किसी के बारे में भी स्पैम मत
कीजिए। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। मैं आपसे
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। प्लीज डोंट स्पैम।
ठीक है? स्पैम क्योंकि फिर वो दिक्कत होती
है।
सब सिखाएंगे भाई। जोकर किंग बिल्कुल
सिखाएंगे। हेलो आरव कैसे हो? प्रीरिसाइट
पहले ही बोल दिया। देयर इज नो प्री
रिक्वसाइट ऑफ दिस कोर्स। जो मैं आपको सिखा
रहा हूं, जैसे सिखा रहा हूं, सीखते जाइए।
एक लैपटॉप और इंटरनेट कनेक्टिविटी होनी
चाहिए जो ऑलमोस्ट मैं मानता हूं एक
लैपटॉप, पीसी और इंटरनेट आज के टाइम में
सबके पास होती है। राइट? ओके? नाउ डीएल
टाइम को मिनिमाइज करना एसओसी का मेन
फंक्शनैलिटी है। द टाइम एंड अटैकर स्टेज़
हिडन। ड्यूल टाइम उसी को बोलते हैं। अटैकर
कितने देर तक हिडन रह रहा है एक नेटवर्क
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में उसी को हम
बोलते हैं। विदाउट एसओसी ब्रीचेस आर
डिस्कवर्ड बाय कस्टमर्स और एफबीआई और
इंटेलिजेंस एजेंसीज। अगर एसओसी ना हो तो
कस्टमर्स डिस्कवर करेंगे ब्रचेस को।
इंटेलिजेंस एजेंसीज ब्रीच डिस्कवर करेंगी
ना कि एक एसओसी एनालिस्ट डिस्कवर करेगा।
तो एसओसी का होना तो बहुत जरूरी है।
कॉजिंग मैसिव रेपुटेशन एंड फाइनेंसियल
लॉस। ऐसा होने लगा कि कस्टमर अगर
कस्टमर अगर ये सब करने लगे अ इन सबको
ब्रचेस के बारे में पता लगाने लगे एंड
ब्रीचेस उन कस्टमर डील करने लगे फिर तो
क्या ही रेपुटेशन रह जाएगी कंपनी की राइट
प्रॉब्लम क्या होता है 24/7 ग्लोबल साइबर
अटैक्स है ये ये आपका यही प्रॉब्लम है
जिसको आप सॉल्व करेंगे सॉल्व क्या करेगा
एसओसी सॉल्यूशन सॉल्व करेगा कंटीन्यूअस
मॉनिटरिंग एंड रैपिड ट्रैक आपका काम है एक
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर में
कंटीन्यूअस मॉनिटर करते हुए एंड अटैक्स को
मॉनिटर करना है, ट्रैक करना है। उसके लिए
काम करना है। उसको रिसोंड उसके लिए
रिपोर्ट्स बनाने हैं। काउंटर मेजर करना
है। काउंटर मेजर रिपोर्ट्स बनाने हैं।
एस्केलेट करना है। अगर कोई बहुत ही
कॉम्प्लेक्स अटैक है तो को बड़े लार्ज
स्केल पे अटैक है। तो ये एसओसी इसलिए
एसओसी एक्सिस्ट करते हैं। अब यहां पे आते
हैं। यहां पे एक चीज समझते हैं। एक चीज़
समझेंगे एसओसी, एनओसी और आईआर के बीच में।
अब ये एसओसी एनओसी आईआर ये जो डायग्राम आप
देख रहे हैं सबसे फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस
आपका एसओसी यहां पे आप देख सकते होंगे देन
आपका एनओसी आप देख सकते हैं जिसको नेटवर्क
ऑ्स आप बोल सकते हैं एसओसी सिक्योरिटी
ऑपरेशन सेंटर एनालिस्ट एंड फिर इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस जो इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर्स होते
हैं जो कि उस इंसिडेंट को रिसोंड करते हैं
वो आते हैं आपके ये एक लेयर है। अब इस
लेयर को मैं ऐसे भी आपको बताना चाहूंगा।
कुछ इस तरीके से समझाना चाहूंगा। जब मैं
यहां पे आ रहा हूं वाई एसओसी एग्जिस्ट
वाले पेज पे तो मैं यहां पे आपको दिखाना
चाहता हूं कि एसओसी वर्सेस एनओसी वर्सेस
आईआर टीम क्या होती है?
एसओसी क्या करते हैं? मॉनिटर सिक्योरिटी
इवेंट्स डिटेक्ट थ्रेट्स एंड एनालाइज द
अलर्ट्स। ये एसओसी का काम है। उसके बाद
आते हैं एनओसी। मॉनिटर्स नेटवर्क
परफॉर्मेंस अप टाइम बैंडविथ इशज़। एंड फिर
आते हैं आईआर टीम रिस्पांस टू कंफर्म्ड
इंसिडेंस परफॉर्म फॉरेंसिक्स एंड
कंटेनमेंट। ये पूरा टीम ही है। ये जो है
ना ये सब टीम है। ये एक दूसरे से कनेक्ट
हो के काम करते हैं ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर।
ऐसा नहीं है कि सब अलग-अलग काम करते हैं।
दे आर कनेक्टेड टू ईच अदर एंड दे वर्क
टुगेदर। कितना मजा सोच के सोचो। जस्ट
इमेजिन। सोचो। कोई भी चीज मैं जब बताऊं ना
आपको तो पता है उसको सबसे ज्यादा मैक्सिमम
तरीके से गैब कैसे करोगे? जब उसको आप
इमेजिन करने लगोगे कि अच्छा हां यार मैं
एसओसी हूं एक एनओसी होगा एक आईआर टीम होगी
मैं एस्केलेट करूंगा इधर जाएगी एनओसी टीम
उसको मॉनिटर कर रही है आईआर वाले रिसोंड
करेंगे वाओ व्हाट अ इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर व्हाट
द सिक्योरिटी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर मजा आ जाएगा
फिर अब एवरीडे ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस फेस
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ साइबर अटैक्स फिशिंग ईमेल्स
रसवेयर डेटा ब्रीचेस एंड इनसाइडर थ्रेट्स
अ सिंगल सक्सेसफुल ब्रीच कैन कॉस्ट
मिलियंस इन फाइनेंसियल लॉस लीगल पेनल्टीज
एंड इरिपेरेबल डैमेज टू रेपुटेशन मतलब
डेली अटैक्स हो रहे हैं। सबसे ज्यादा
फिशिंग अटैक्स, रैंसवेयर अटैक्स, डेटा
ब्रचेस हो रहे हैं। इंसाइडर थ्रेट्स आ रहे
हैं। एंड एक भी ब्रीच हुआ तो यह एक बहुत
बड़ा फाइनेंसियल लॉस होता है कंपनीज़ के
लिए। रेपुटेशन का डैमेज होता है। आपने
सुना होगा ना एक एक
पासवर्ड मैनेजर था। एक पासवर्ड मैनेजर
एप्लीकेशन थी। आप में से कई लोग जानते
हैं। लास्ट पास। आप में से कई लोगों को
पता भी होगा। कितने लोगों को पता है लास्ट
पास के बारे में? एक पासवर्ड मैनेजर था,
पासवर्ड वाल्ट मैनेजर था जिसमें कि आप
अपने पासवर्ड को स्टोर करके रख सकते थे और
कहीं भी यूज़ करना हो बस एक सिंगल क्लिक
कीजिए। वो पासवर्ड वहां पे प्रीफिल्ड हो
जाता था और वहां पे एक क्लाउड में स्टोरेज
होती थी लास्ट पास की। डू यू नो? आपको याद
है लास्ट पास?
बताइए मुझे। रिप्लाई रिप्लाई कर दीजिए चैट
में जल्दी से जितने लोग हैं, जितने भी लोग
हैं फटाफट रिप्लाई मार दीजिए। डू यू
रिमेंबर लास्ट पास? हां।
बस अब सोचो एक डाटा ब्रीच हुई एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ लास्ट पास के सर्वर एंड
लास्ट पास इज गॉन फॉर एवर लास्ट पास चला
गया नोबडी यूज़ लास्ट पास नाउ अ डेज़
इक्कादुक्का यूज़ पता नहीं कोई नहीं यूज़
करता यार लास्ट पास
लास्ट पास लॉस्ट इट्स रेपुटेशन ओवर द
मार्केट इतना बड़ा मार्केट शेयर था उनका
लाखों यूज़र्स आई मीन करोड़ों यूज़र्स यूज़
करते थे लास्ट पास को एक अटैक एक ब्रीच
एंड एंड एवरीथिंग डिस्ट्रॉयड दिस लेवल ऑफ़
इंपैक्ट कैन हैपन व्हनेवर देयर इज़ डेटा
ब्रच व्हेनएवर देयर इज़ फिशिंग अटैक
व्हेनएवर देयर इज़ रसलवेयर अटैक व्हेनएवर
देयर इज़ सम इंसाइडर थ्रेड सर्कुलेटिंग एंड
इसी को डिफेंड तो आप करते हैं एज अ फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस एज़ एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट।
प्राउड फील करो यार। प्राउड फील करो अगर
आप इस चीज़ के लिए प्रिपेयर कर रहे हो तो।
नाउ द सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर्स एसओसी
एकिस्ट एस द फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस
मॉनिटरिंग नेटवर्क्स 24 * 7 टू डिटेक्ट
एनालाइज एंड रिस्पॉनड टू दीज़ थ्रेट्स
बिफोर दे कॉज कैटस्ट्रोफिक डैमेज। बहुत
बड़े डैमेज से पहले ही यह रिसोंड करते हैं,
डिटेक्ट करते हैं एंड डिफेंस करते हैं एंड
रिसोंड करते हैं ऐसे अटैक्स के लिए। यही
काम है आपका। याद रखिएगा अपने काम को
समझिएगा। हम इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग में हैंड्स
ऑन भी करेंगे, प्रैक्टिकल्स भी है, लैब्स
हैं, सब चीजें करेंगे। बट पेशेंस रखना
पड़ेगा। एक-एक चीज जो मैं जैसे वे में बता
रहा हूं ना वैसे समझना है। अगर आपको उस
लेवल की प्रिपरेशन चाहिए, जॉब रेडी वाली
प्रिपरेशन चाहिए तो तो आपको एक-एक छोटी
चीज को भी पकड़ के रखना होगा। इंटरव्यूअर
पूछ देगा क्या करोगे? एसओसी पढ़ते-पढ़ते
चले गए। एसओसी पूरा पढ़ के तैयारी करके आ
गए। पूछ देगा एसओसी, एनओसी, आईआर टीम के
बीच का डिफरेंस बताइए। क्या करोगे?
सोचोगे? अरे भाई ये तो पढ़ा ही नहीं था।
मैंने तो एसओसी बस पढ़ा था। एनओसीआईआर क्या
होता है? तो हर एक चीज कवर करते चलूंगा।
बेफिक्र रहिए। ठीक है? एसओसी टीम्स
प्रिवेंट ब्रिजेचेस दैट कुड शट डाउन
हॉस्पिटल्स। स्टिल कस्टमर डेटा फ्रॉम
बैंक्स। हॉस्पिटल्स बंद कर सकते हैं।
कस्टमर डाटा चुरा सकते हैं बैंक से।
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को पूरी तरीके से क्रिपल
कर सकते हैं। रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल्स लाइक
द वना क्राई रैंसमवेयर अटैक। 2017 में वना
क्राई रैंसमवेयर अटैक आया था। आप सबको
अच्छे से याद होगा अफेक्टिंग
2 लाख से भी ज्यादा कंप्यूटरटर्स को
वर्ल्ड वाइड इंटरनली स्प्रेड अप हो रहा था
वो मालवेयर एंड अटैक ल्च हुआ एक बड़े स्केल
पे सभी को लगा कि अरे ये क्या हो रहा है
और द इक्विफक्स ब्रीच एक्सपोजिंग 147
मिलियन रिकॉर्ड्स इक्विफक्स का ब्रीच डाटा
ब्रीच हुआ था 147 मिलियन रिकॉर्ड्स जो है
ब्रीच हुए थे डेमोंस्ट्रेट वई एसओसी
विजिलेंस मैटर्स इसी से पता चलता है व्हाई
एसओसी मैटर्स देयर दीज़ वेर नॉट इन इनएटेबल
प्रॉपर एसओसी डिटेक्शन कुड हैव मिनिमाइज्ड
इंपैक्ट सिग्निफिकेंटली ये इनएविएटेबल तो
नहीं थे बट स्टिल अगर प्रॉपर एसोसिएट
डिटेक्शन होती या कुछ कमियां जो रह गई थी
अगर वो ना होती तो शायद इन चीजों से उनको
रोका जा सकता था उन अटैक्स को उन
मैल्वेस्ट्स को शायद इतना बड़े लेवल पे
रेप्लिकेट होने से रोका जा सकता था। दैट्स
द थिंग। अब एग्जांपल के तौर पे थिंक ऑफ
एसओसी एस द वॉच वॉच टावर कास्टेंटली
स्कैनिंग फॉर एनमीज़। अब मैं आपको एक
एग्जांपल के तौर पे बता देता हूं। समझ
जाइएगा। आपने देखा होगा हॉलीवुड की
फिल्म्स होती है या गेम्स होती है। आईजीआई
गेम करके आता था। ऐसे बहुत सारे गेम्स हैं
जिसमें क्या होता है? वॉच टावर्स होते
हैं। लंबे-लंबे टावर्स होते हैं। उस पे
स्नाइपर लेके या बंदूके लेके वॉच टावर्स
जो होते हैं उस पे उस पे गन मैन खड़े होते
हैं। जिनको वॉच डॉग्स बोल लो आप जो कि
मॉनिटरिंग करते रहते हैं चारों तरफ एक
प्रेमाइसेस का एक पूरे लोकालिटी का कि
भैया कोई कोई बहुत ही सीक्रेट लोकालिटी है
या कोई बहुत ही हाईली सेंसिटिव लोकालिटी
है या आर्मी लोकेशन है तो वहां पे वो खड़े
हो के मॉनिटरिंग करते रहते हैं तो आप
एसओसी को समझ लो वो वॉच टावर है जहां पे
जहां जो कि कम कंटीन्यूअस मॉनिटर कर रहा
है आपके एनमीज़ को एनओसी जो है वो वॉल्स को
समझ लो जो फेंसेस हैं चारों तरफ उसको आप
एनओसी समझ लो जो पूरी पूरी तरीके से
घेराबंदी हुई है। एंड आईआरएस द स्पेशल
फोर्सेस डिप्लॉयड व्हेन अटैकर्स ब्रीच द
डिफेंस। एंड इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर्स उनको
समझ लो जो स्पेशल फोर्सेस इंडियन आर्मी जो
खड़ी है कि भैया इनको तो पूरा उड़ा देंगे।
एंड अगर कोई ये एंट्री करने की कोशिश करता
है तो ये आईआर है। अब मुझे लगता है कि
एसओसी, एनओसी और आईआर के बीच में कोई
डिफरेंस पूछेगा तो दुनिया के किसी भी कोने
में कोई भी इंटरव्यूअर आपसे पूछ ले आप इस
तरह का एग्जांपल दे देना। इसी से सिमिलर
एग्जांपल इसी टाइप के एग्जांपल दे देना
एंड वो समझ जाएगा कि आपका कांसेप्ट
बिल्कुल क्लियर है। एंड वो आपसे ज्यादा
हिम्मत नहीं करेगा आगे पूछने की क्योंकि
उसको पता है कि आपका कांसेप्ट क्लियर है।
बेसिक चीजें ही आपका क्लियर है ना। बेसिक
चीजें क्लियर है सब क्लियर है। बेसिक
चीजों पे ही तो काम होता है। पहले एक
प्रोटोटाइप बनती है। जब एरोप्लेन का
डिस्कवरी हुआ था। एरोप्लेन जब इन चीजों की
जब भी बल्ब होती है तो हर चीज की एक
प्रोटोटाइप होती है। छोटी सी चीज होती है।
जैसे खिलौने टाइप होता है और उसी को बड़ा
एक एक्सपोनेंशियल एंड एक वर्किंग तरीके से
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है। तो आपको समझ में
आ गया होगा। राइट?
लव यू सर।
लव यू टू ब्रदर।
नॉन आईटी पर्सन है। कोई बात नहीं। स्किल
सीखिए।
हां
हां और जो भी आपको रिसोर्सेज हैं जो भी
आपको रिसोर्सेज मिलेंगे इस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग के रिगार्डिंग जितने भी
रिसोर्सेज हैं या जो भी आपको नोट्स हैं जो
भी चीजें मिलनी होंगी ना WhatsApp ग्रुप
जो आप ज्वाइन करेंगे उसी के अंदर आपको
अपडेट आ जाएंगी सारी कि कहां पे आपको
मिलनी है कैसे मिलनी है। तो इसीलिए मैंने
बोला था ग्रुप जरूर जॉइ कीजिएगा।
सर्टिफिकेशन की भी डिटेल उसी ग्रुप में
आएगी। सब चीजें की डिटेल उसी में आएगी।
इवन टाइम टू टाइम WhatsApp ग्रुप को ओपन
भी करेंगे तो आप वहां पर जाकर एक दूसरे से
इंटरेक्शन भी कर सकते हैं।
तो अभी समझ में आया आपको इन दोनों इन
तीनों के बीच की डिफरेंस समझ में आ गई।
एसओसी एक वॉच टावर है जो पूरी इनेस को
मॉनिटर कर रहा है। एनओसी पूरी फेंस है जो
घेराबंदी की हुई है और स्पेशल फोर्सेस हैं
आईआर इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर। इससे आपको
क्लियर हो गई होगी। एवरीथिंग क्लियर बताइए
मुझे
बताइए। प्लीज बताइए। सर वीक में कितने
लेक्चर होंगे? इससे मतलब मत रखिए। वीक में
मैं कोशिश करूंगा दो-तीन लेक्चर एटलीस्ट आ
जाए। बट उससे मतलब मत रखिए। मैं कोशिश
करूंगा फ्रीक्वेंसी ज्यादा अच्छी हो।
रेगुलर बेसिस पे आपकी ये क्लासेस आ एंड
जिस तरीके से मैं लेकर आ रहा हूं जो मैं
बता रहा हूं बस उसको सीखते रहिएगा। एक जो
क्लासेस आएंगी उस पे आपको कम से कम 2 दिन
का टाइम देके उसकी प्रैक्टिस और उसको
रिपीट करना है। उसको मेमोराइज करनी है।
नोट्स बनाने हैं। Lindin पे डालना है।
बहुत कम लोग बोल रहे हैं यस सर। मुझे लगता
है काफी लोग सबको नहीं समझ में आया क्या?
अगर सबको समझ में आया तो मुझे सबसे यस
चाहिए। क्योंकि जब आप रिप्लाई करोगे तो
मुझे मजा आता है। भाई मुझे रिप्लाई में
मजा आएगा और क्या आएगा? [हंसी] मैं तो
सिखा रहा हूं। रिप्लाई में मजा आएगा और
क्या?
अब मजे-मजे में सीखना है यार। कोई टेंशन
नहीं। लोड नहीं लेना है। दिमाग पे लोड लिए
बिना सीखना है। धड़ल्ले से। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। थैंक यू। अरे अरे अरे कुछ ज्यादा ही
यस यस कर दिया। लगता है। चैट कुछ ज्यादा
ही एक्सप्रेसवेट तरीके से फास्ट हो गई है।
थैंक्स थैंक्स गाइस। इतना प्यार दिखाने के
लिए।
चलिए मैं आपको कुछ टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट अब
बता देता हूं क्योंकि उनका मतलब यह एफर्ट
दिखना चाहिए यहां पे। मैं आपको दिखाना
चाहता हूं यहां पे टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट। सो
यहां पर यूज़र्स जो सबसे ज्यादा देर तक
एक्टिव रहते हैं। सबसे ज्यादा एक्टिव रहते
हैं। तो एंड कंटिन्यू रहते हैं। सो दीज़ आर
आरव आरव यहां पे अह स्क्रॉल विथ करके हैं
यहां पे अह देन अह दृष्टि पांडे देन शाई
सिंह ऋषु रॉकी भाई हरीश मैं नाम सबके तो
बोल नहीं सकता क्योंकि नाम अजीब अजीब रखते
हो आप लोग यार तो नाम बोलने में मजा नहीं
आता मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि मैं क्या बोलूं
ठीक है विरल विकास ये ये सारे जो लोग हैं
यह हमारे टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट में आप देख
सकते हैं
दीज़ पीपल एक्चुअली
नीड रिकॉग्नाइजेशन यहां पे 50 लोग यहां पर
दिए हुए हैं आदित्य सिंह तक। तो इन 50 टॉप
फैंस लिस्ट में जो भी आए हैं और इनफैक्ट
जितने भी लोग यहां हैं आप सबको
अ
आप सबको थैंक यू बोलना चाहूंगा क्योंकि
आपने इतना अपना कीमती समय निकाला है इस
ट्रेनिंग के लिए एंड आई होप कि वह वर्थ
रहेगा इस ट्रेनिंग को करने का। आई आई होप
कि वर्थ रहेगा यह आपका जो टाइम है मैं
आपको इस इस टाइम का इस टाइम की पूरी आपकी
पूरा वर्थ बना दूंगा टेंशन मत लो आप बस आप
फॉलो करो
ओके ये आपने डिफरेंस समझ लिया ठीक है
अब अब आते हैं यहां पे वापस यहां पे ठीक
है अब आते हैं यहां पे यहां पे एल1
एनालिस्ट का लाइफ कैसा होता है एज एनुअल
एल1 एनालिस्ट आपकी कैसी लाइफ होगी किस तरह
की जिंदगी जिओगे आप ये भी तो देखना जरूरी
है कैसी जिंदगी है भाई तो देखो देखो यहां
पे डेली शिफ्ट एलोकेशन कुछ इस तरीके से
होती है। सबसे ज्यादा टाइम आप देते हो
अलर्ट ट्राइग एंड रिपोर्टिंग पे एंड देन
फिल्टरिंग फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स पे। इस पे आप
सबसे ज्यादा टाइम देते हो। देन आप रिसर्च
पे भी टाइम देते हो। देन आप फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स को फिल्टर करते हो। यह आपका
डेली शिफ्ट एलोकेशन है। कुछ इस तरीके से
सबसे ज्यादा अलर्ट ट्रैक एंड रिपोर्टिंग
होती है आपके लिए एल1 के लिए। मतलब कोई भी
अलर्ट आया तुरंत उसको ट्राई करके रिपोर्ट
करना रिपोर्ट बनाना मॉनिटर करना ये आपका
सबसे मेजर वर्क है। तो सबसे अ जो ये पूरी
एक प्रोसेस होती है जो लूप होती है एल वन
के लिए जो ट्रैक प्रोसेस है उस ट्रैक
प्रोसेस में क्या-क्या स्टेप्स इन्वॉल्वड
हैं? पहला है अलर्ट। एसआईएम ट्रिगर्स रूल।
एसआईएम जो टूल्स होते हैं जो एसआईएम
टेक्नोलॉजी है जो भी आप सॉफ्टवेयर यूज कर
रहे हैं वो एक रूल पे काम करती है। उसमें
एक रूल डिफाइंड होता है। किस तरह से कुछ
होगा। ठीक है? प्लीज डोंट स्पैम अ
जिंदगी दोबारा।
वाह क्या एग्जांपल समझाया एसओसी एनओसी एंड
आईआर का सर। लाजवाब। थैंक यू रुद्र ब्रदर।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। आई होप कि आपको अच्छा
लगा होगा। प्लीज आप लोग स्पैम नहीं
कीजिएगा। स्पैम करने पे क्या होता है कि
कई लोग इंपॉर्टेंट कमेंट्स लोग नहीं कर
पाते हैं। तो मैं वैसे स्पैम्स को टाइम
आउट में डाल देता हूं ताकि आप कुछ देर तक
स्पैम ना करें। अगर ज्यादा फिर से करेंगे
तो आपको मल्टी मैक्सिमम टाइम के लिए वो
डालना डालना पड़ेगा टाइम आउट में। तो इट्स
अ रिक्वेस्ट कि प्लीज डोंट डू दैट। राइट?
आप फोकस कीजिए इधर। ओके? पहला जो प्रोसेस
है वो है अलर्ट का। एसआईएम के ट्रिगर्स
होते हैं रूल्स। रूल्स के अकॉर्डिंग
ट्रिगर्स होते हैं एसआईएम के अंदर में। जो
भी रूल्स डिफाइन है कि अगर ऐसा होगा इस
तरह का कुछ पैटर्न होगा तो ये रूल इनवोक
हो के एंड ये ट्रिगर हो जाएगी। तो पहले
अलर्ट होता है। दूसरा एनालिसिस होती है
जहां पे आप एज अ एसोसिएशनलिस्ट एनालिसिस
करते हैं। देन आप डिसीजन बनाते हैं कि ये
फॉल्स है या ट्रू है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव तो
नहीं है। फॉल्स नेगेटिव है या जेन्युइन
अलर्ट है। मतलब जो भी अलर्ट्स आ रही हैं
उसमें फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स भी होने के चांसेस
होते हैं। जी हां। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स का
मतलब है हो सकता है कि वह जो अलर्ट है वह
एक रॉन्ग अलर्ट हो। कभी-कभी हो जाता है।
टूल ही है। इंसानों ने बनाया है। गलतियां
हो जाती हैं। बेचारा टूल हमेशा सही काम कर
दे। जरूरी तो नहीं है। अब 99.9% सही काम
करेगा 1% को फिर भी चांसेस होते हैं कुछ
गलत अलर्ट दे देने का। तो ये डिसीजन भी आप
ही का काम है बनाना भैया। कि फॉल्स है
ट्रू है। उसके बाद है एक्शन। एक्शन में
क्या होगा कि अगर फॉल्स पॉजिटिव होंगे,
फॉल्स अलर्ट होगा तो क्लोज कर दोगे आप।
जाओ डब्बा। खत्म कहानी। लेकिन अगर यह कोई
कॉम्प्लेक्स या ऐसी कोई अलर्ट है जिसको
एस्केलेट करना चाहिए तो इट्स टाइम टू
एस्केलेट एस्केलेट करेंगे L2 L3 अपर आपके
सीनियर्स को ये पूरी की पूरी आपकी
टाइमलाइन है जो कि आप फॉलो करोगे एज अ
एसओसी एनालिस्ट यही है आपका टाइमलाइन है
शानदार टाइमलाइन
अब देखो
क्रिटिकल एल1 मिस्टेक्स एल1 जो है एसओसी
मैं यहां पे एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल1 जब भी मैं
एल1 बात करूंगा तो एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल वन
की बात है। समझ जाइएगा। इग्नोरिंग अलर्ट्स
बिकॉज़ इट्स प्रोबेबबली नथिंग और फेलिंग टू
डॉक्यूमेंट योर फाइंडिंग्स इन द टिकट। इफ
इट इज़ नॉट डॉक्यूमेंटेड इट डिड नॉट हैपन।
एल1 के लिए ये बहुत बड़ी चीज है। ये बहुत
बड़ा पॉइंट है। याद रखिएगा। यह आपका
इंटरव्यूअर भी पूछ सकता है कि अगर मान लो
कि कोई अलर्ट है एंड आपको लग रहा है कि
यार यह तो कुछ भी नहीं है। तो उस केस में
आपको क्या ट्रिगर करना है? आपको कुछ आपको
कुछ करना है या क्लोज कर देना है। तो आपको
वहां पे बोलना है कि आई डोंट हैव टू
इग्नोर सच थिंग्स एंड आई डोंट हैव टू इवन
थिंक कि इट्स प्रोबेबबली नथिंग एंड आई हैव
टू डॉक्यूमेंट एवरीथिंग। इवन इट्स नथिंग
आई हैव टू डॉक्यूमेंट इट। अगर किसी भी तरह
का प्रोबेबल एक अटैक है तो ये मिस्टेक
होती है कि कई ऐसे एल1 होते हैं। उसको
इग्नोर कर देते हैं। डॉक्यूमेंट नहीं करते
हैं। तो यह आपको नहीं करना है। एज अ एल1
एनालिस्ट जब भी आप किसी कॉर्पोरेट में काम
करेंगे तो टिकट क्या होती है? फाइंडिंग इन
द टिकट बताऊंगा मैं टिकट्स ऐप टिकट्स
रिलेटेड सॉफ्टवेयर्स होते हैं जहां पे आप
टिकट्स रेज करते हैं टिकट्स बनाते हैं मैं
आपको वो सब चीज बताऊंगा जैसे कि आपका zरा
है zerरा पे भी आप टिकटिंग करते हैं
टिकटिंग सॉफ्टवेयर्स भी इसको हम बोलते हैं
जिसका काफी ज्यादा रोल है
ड्यूरिंग एसओसी एसओसी एनालिस्ट का हर चीज
समझेंगे हम एक-एक चीज करके आपको सब समझ
में आएगा
अब यहां पे आती है द आर्शनल द आर्शनल ठीक
है अब ये जो गाइज पूरा पूरा आपको मैं ये
HTML पेज दिखा रहा हूं। ये कोई वेबसाइट पे
नहीं है। याद रखिएगा ये मेरे लोकल सिस्टम
पे है। रोडmaphtml करके मैंने आपके लिए
बनाई है। एंड वही मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं
ताकि आपको प्रॉपर वे में एक अच्छे तरीके
से समझा सकूं सारी चीजें। मतलब ग्राफिकली
थ्यरिटिकली हैंड्स ऑन लैब सब कुछ जब मिला
देंगे ना तो बहुत परफेक्ट एक ट्रेनिंग
तैयार हो जाता है। एंड आपको अच्छे से समझ
में आता है। एंड मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि आप
अभी तक जितने भी चीजें मैंने आपको अभी तक
सिखाई है अभी तक जो भी चीजें मैंने बताई
है आपके दिमाग में घुस गया होगा क्योंकि
आप विजुअलाइज कर पा रहे हैं चीजों को एक
चीजों को समझ पा रहे हैं और अगर नहीं भी
घुसे ना तो ऐसे कोई भी चीज बताऊं सोचने
लगो इमेजिन करने लगो उसको टन टना मजा आ
जाएगा हो जाएगा अब देखो यू डोंट नीड टू
कोड लाइक अ डेव डेवलपर की तरह कोड नहीं
करना है आपको बीइंग अ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट
बट यू मस्ट क्वीरी लाइक अ डिटेक्टिव बट एक
डिटेक्टिव बन के रहना है दीज़ आर द वेपन्स
यू मस्ट मास्टर यह कुछ वेपन्स है जिसको
आपको मास्टर करना है। वेपन्स में किस टाइप
के वेपन्स हैं? पहले तो एसआईएम। अब एसआईएम
क्या है गाइस? एसआईएम इज़ अ टेक्नोलॉजी।
अब एसआईएम के काफी टूल्स आते हैं। एसआईएम
बेस्ड काफी टूल्स आते हैं। जैसे कि
स्प्लंक जैसे कि अब ये मैं इसको हटा देता
हूं पहले। जैसे कि स्प्लंक, सेंटिनेल।
देयर आर मल्टीपल टूल्स। अब
लाइक स्प्लंक एक एसआईएम तो नहीं है। स्प
फुल्ली एसआईएम उसको नहीं बोलते इस प्लंक
को बट स्टिल एसआईएम के सारे फंक्शनैलिटीज
आप उस पे कर सकते हैं। बेसिकली लॉग्स एंड
मॉनिटरिंग इन सबके लिए काफी यूज़फुल होता
है। ऑटोमेशन काफी यूज़फुल होता है। उसके
बाद आती है ईडीआर। ईडीआर पे भी हम
जानेंगे। इडीआर को भी हम कवर करेंगे। हम
ईडीआर को भी समझेंगे कि एक्सक्टली ईडीआर
होता क्या है? किस तरीके से एक डिफेंस
सिस्टम में एडीआर का काफी बड़ा रोल होता
है। स्पेशली एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट के लिए।
जैसे कि एग्जांपल है क्राउड स्ट्राइक का
आईडिया। ऐसे बहुत सारे इडियर्स आते हैं।
टिकटिंग टिकटिंग मैनेजिंग एंड इंटरेक्टिंग
विद द डॉक्यूमेंटेशन जिस तरीके से भी है
वो सब टिकटिंग के अंदर में आता है। जैसे
कि सर्विस नाउ zरा ऐसे टिकटिंग के
एप्लीकेशन सॉफ्टवेयर्स आते हैं। तो यू कैन
यू विल बी लर्निंग अबाउट दीज़। हां देखो
एसओएआर सोर्स जिसको बोलते हैं क्यूरेडार
सेंटिनेल बहुत सारे एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं। हम
हर चीज को ना टच करने वाले हैं। तो
बेफिक्र रहने का उसके लिए ठीक है? ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी इसी का पार्ट है। नेटवर्क
लॉग्स फायर वॉल इसी का पार्ट है। थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस जैसे कि वायरस टोटल से बहुत
सारे लोग थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस करते हैं। ये
भी इसी का पार्ट है। तो ये सारी चीजें जो
हैं आपको कवर करनी है। ये सारी चीजें जो
हैं इसमें आपको नॉलेज लेनी है। एसआईएम की
नॉलेज लेनी है, एडीआर की नॉलेज लेनी है,
टिकटिंग की नॉलेज लेनी है, ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी की लेनी है, नेटवर्किंग की
लेनी है, नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की लेनी है,
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस की लेनी है। एंड जब आप
इन सब की ले लोगे नॉलेज तो आप बन जाओगे एक
प्रोफेशनल एसओसी एल1 एंड आप अप्लाई कर
पाओगे एल1 रोल्स के लिए। अब इससे बड़ा
प्रॉमिस क्या दे सकता है एक फ्री ट्रेनिंग
के साथ कि आपको एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए
प्रिपेयर करा देगी ये ट्रेनिंग।
बस अच्छा हां मैं एक चीज ईडीआर भी
समझाऊंगा। मैं हर चीज समझाऊंगा। ठीक है?
आप टेंशन नहीं लो। ठीक है? बिल्कुल
बेफिक्र रहो आप। ठीक है? अगर आपको ऐसा लग
रहा है ना कि सर ये इडीआर क्या होता है?
सर ये एसआईएम क्या होता है? तो अभी तो
हमने शुरुआत की है मेरे भाई। अभी तो मंजिल
दूर है। अभी तो मंजिल अभी चलना शुरू किया
है। मंजिल तक भी पहुंच जाएंगे। और जब
मंजिल तक पहुंच जाएंगे तो आप लास्ट में ये
सब चीजें जान जाएंगे। आप इनफैक्ट मास्टर
हो जाएंगे। आपको लगेगा अरे एसआईएम अरे सर
फर्स्ट क्लास में ना मुझे एसआईएम जब मैंने
देखा था तो मैं सोचा एसआईएम क्या होता है?
अभी तो मैं एसआईएम पे काम कर रहा हूं।
एसआईएम टूल्स स्प्ल सेंटिनल पे काम कर रहा
हूं। इडीआर टूल्स पे काम कर रहा हूं। तो
आपको वह डिफरेंस नजर आएगा आज फर्स्ट डे
में एंड लास्ट डे जब आप यह स्किल्स गेन कर
लेंगे एंड तब मुझे मजा आएगा एंड मैं सबसे
ज्यादा खुश तब होऊंगा इन रियल जब आप में
से लोगों के प्लेसमेंट्स होंगे एसओसीएल वन
रोल के लिए एंड जब प्लेसमेंट्स होंगे तो
आप Lindin पर जरूर डालिएगा कि आई गॉट
प्लेस्ड एज अ एसओसीएल वन एंड अगर क्रेडिट
देना हो तो दे दीजिएगा नहीं देना हो तो मत
दीजिएगा लेकिन कम से कम डाल के हमें टैग
जरूर कर दीजिएगा। क्रेडिट दीजिए मत दीजिए।
आपकी मर्जी है। बट एसओसी में प्लेसमेंट हो
गया है। बस इतना बता दीजिएगा कि आपने
डिफ़्रॉनिस की एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग देखी है।
बस देखी है बोल दीजिएगा। क्रेडिट ऐसे देने
की जरूरत नहीं है कि हां इसी की वजह से
हुआ है। वी डोंट नीड दैट। आई डोंट नीड
दैट। बट जब बता देंगे आप तो हमें जब पता
चलेगा जब मुझे पता चलेगा तो आई विल बी द
मोस्ट हैप्पीएस्ट पर्सन इन दिस यूनिवर्स।
सो आई विल ट्राई माय बेस्ट। आई विल गिव
माय 200% टू एवरीबॉडी सो दैट यू लैंड अ
जॉब इन एसओसी एज़ एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल वन
प्रोफाइल एंड बाय जस्ट गोइंग थ्रू दिस
पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग बस ये ट्रेनिंग
कंप्लीट करके सर्टिफिकेशन हमारी होगी लेना
आप करना होगा तो करेंगे नहीं करना होगा
नहीं करेंगे उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है
बट स्किल्स पूरा आपको लेके जाना है बस
इतना ही मैं बोलूंगा थैंक यू चलिए
श्योर श्योर श्योर सर योर एनर्जी इज
अब्सोलुटली अमेजिंग थैंक यू थैंक यू उमर
फारूक ब्रदर थैंक यू वेरी मच योर टीचिंग
अमेजिंग थैंक यू ललित थैंक यू वेरी मच
अच्छा मुझे मुझे बस इतना बता दीजिए मुझे
बस इतना बता दीजिए कि आपकी प्लेसमेंट होगी
अगर एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए इस ट्रेनिंग की
हेल्प से या ट्रेनिंग का कहीं भी पार्ट
होगा तो आप Lindin पे डालोगे हमें टैग
करोगे कि नहीं डिफ्रॉनिस्ट को पहले मुझे
बताओ मुझे जानना है यह चीज
करोगे या नहीं करोगे और जो वीडियोस आएंगे
उनको शेयर करोगे कि नहीं लोगों के बीच
जिनको चाहिए या अपने ग्रुप्स में या ऐसे
ताकि मैक्सिमम लोगों तक पहुंचे मुझे बताइए
करेंगे काफी लोग करेंगे थैंक यू थैंक यू
वेरी मच अच्छा लगा जान के एंड शेयर भी
करना है देखो शेयर करने के लिए मैं क्यों
बोल रहा हूं आप सोच रहे होंगे कि अरे सर
आप शेयर शेयर करते रहते हो शेयर करने के
लिए इसलिए बोलता हूं कि जितने लोगों तक
शेयर करोगे ज्यादा मैक्सिमम लोगों तक ये
ट्रेनिंग ये फ्री ट्रेनिंग है मैक्सिमम
लोगों तक पहुंचेगी हमारे ट्रेनिंग के ऊपर
व्यूज भी आएंगे ऑब्वियस सी बात है और जब
व्यूज अच्छे आएंगे ना तो हमें लगेगा कि आप
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टेड हैं। जब आप लाइव में
ज्यादा आएंगे ना तो हमें लगेगा ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टेड हैं। तो हमारे ऊपर एक प्रेशर
बनता है। मेरे ऊपर एक प्रेशर बनेगा कि ये
क्लासेस रेगुलर बैक टू बैक लेकर आनी है।
क्योंकि लोग वेट कर रहे हैं वहां पे। तो
ये आपके हाथों में है। मैं पहले ही बता
रहा हूं। इट्स टोटली अप टू यू। ठीक है? अब
देखिए एसआईएम जो कि ब्रेन कहलाता है। इिया
जिसको हैंड्स बोलते हैं और टिकटिंग जिसको
लॉग बुक बोलते हैं। अब ब्रेन जैसे कि
स्प्लंक, सेंटिनेल, क्यू रेडर ये सब लॉग्स
को कलेक्ट करते हैं। वैसे जो सॉफ्टवेयर्स
होते हैं एसआईएम सॉफ्टवेयर्स इनका काम है
लॉग्स को कलेक्ट करना। दीज़ आर यूज़्ड टू
कलेक्ट लॉग्स। टास्क क्या करना होता है?
लर्न एसएल। आपका टास्क क्या है? लर्न
एसएल, स्प्लंक या सेंटिनेल। यह सीखना है।
यू मस्ट नो हाउ टू फिल्टर। मतलब फिल्टर
फिल्टर्स कैसे लगाते हैं? कैसे फिल्टर
करें? जैसे आपने क्या होता है? जैसे आपने
वॉइस शार्क में फ़्टर्स का यूज़ किया होगा।
वैसे टाइप के कुछ फ़िल्टर्स होते हैं। ये
सीखने हैं। तो अब ये जो टास्क है ये तो
मैंने यहां पे लिखा हुआ है। बट ये
सिखाऊंगा मैं ही। तो ऐसा नहीं सोचना है कि
सर अरे सर ये हमें सीखना है क्या खुद से?
नहीं। हम मैं सिखाऊंगा यार। टेंशन मत लो।
मतलब एज अ टास्क है कि एसएल आपको स्प्लंक
या सेंटिनल सीखना है। दोनों में से कोई एक
भी सीख लेंगे चलेगा। जरूरी नहीं है कि
दोनों सीखे तीनों सीखे। डज़ंट रिक डिड नॉट
डिड मतलब इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड सिंपल सा
बात है। उसके बाद है ईडीआर द हैंड्स क्या
है टूल्स जैसे क्राउड स्ट्राइक डिफेंडर
डिफेंडर वही Microsoft वाली सेंटल वन इट
वॉचेस द एंड पॉइंट एंड पॉइंट की वॉच
वॉचिंग करते हैं ये आपका इसमें टास्क क्या
होगा या हम कैसे करेंगे चेक प्रोसेस फ्री
ठीक है डिडexlex स्पॉन powerlxee
दैट इज मलेशियस। यह भी देखना है। अब एक
प्रोसेस दूसरे प्रोसेस को स्पॉन तो नहीं
कर दे रहा है। एक प्रोसेस दूसरे प्रोसेस
को डुप्लीकेट तो नहीं कर दे रहा है। एक
प्रोसेस दूसरे प्रोसेस को ओवरलैप तो नहीं
कर दे रहा है। जंप तो नहीं कर दे रहा। ये
सब भी देखना है। दिस इज़ द वर्क ऑफ़ इडिया।
एंड देन टिकटिंग जो कि जैसे सर्विस नाउ
ज़ीरा क्या होता है? राइट क्लियर कंसाइज़
नोट्स। कैसे लिखते हैं? ये सब भी हम
देखेंगे। यूजर डाउनलोडेड फाइल एक्स हैश
मैचेस मैलिस मॉस होस्ट आइसोलेटेड। यूजर ने
कोई फाइल डाउनलोड की एक्स#श
जो है वो मैच मलिशियस हैश से मैच हुई है
एंड जो आपका मेन होस्ट है उसको हटा दिया
गया आइसोलेट कर दिया गया है ये इसको पूरी
की पूरी डॉक्यूमेंटेशन के थ्रू इसको बताना
पड़ता है कि भैया एक एक यूजर ने फाइल
डाउनलोड करी थी इसका जो हैश है वो तो
मलेशियस फाइल से मैच हुआ है एक एंड इस
पूरे हमारे होस्ट सिस्टम को हमने आइसोलेट
हमें आइसोलेट करना पड़े कर करना पड़ा इसकी
वजह से तो यह आपको लॉग ये आपको लॉग्स मतलब
एक पूरी बुक बनानी है आपको एज अ
एसोसिएशनलिस्ट। यह काम आप करते हैं। यह
चीजें आपके अंदर में होती है। अब है नो
योर एमी। यू कैन नॉट डिफेंड अगेंस्ट व्हाट
यू डू नॉट अंडरस्टैंड। हियर आर द टॉप अटैक
वेक्टर्स एंड एल1 फसेस। एल1 के लिए सबसे
टॉप अटैक वेक्टर्स क्या है? वो यहीं पे
हैं। जो मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं। क्योंकि
बिना एनिमी को जाने आप डिफेंड किससे
करोगे? है ना? देखते होंगे आप मूवीज़ देखते
हैं मार्वेल की। है ना? अब कोई इनविज़िबल
एनिमी आ जाए तो भैया जब दिख ही नहीं रहा
तो डिफेंड कैसे करेंगे? है ना? वही सेम
चीज है। तो क्या है? अटैक वॉल्यूम वर्सेस
एनालिसिस डिफिकल्टी की मैं यहां पे बात कर
रहा हूं। एंड यहां पे जो सबसे अ टॉप अटैक
वेक्टर्स जो हैं वो हैं फिशिंग, वो है
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स एंड वो है रैंसमवेयर। यह तीन
टॉप के अटैक वेक्टर्स हैं जो कि एक
सिक्योरिटी एसओसी सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट एल1
के तौर पर आपको डील करने पड़ेंगे इनसे। यू
हैव टू डील इट विद
तो फिशिंग ब्रूट फ़ोर्स एंड रंस अवेयर। अब
इस जब आप इस पूरे की पूरी चार्ट को
देखेंगे एक्स व एक्सिस को तो आप देखेंगे
बिगर बबल्स इक्वल टू हाई सीवियरिटी रिस्क।
एक्स एक्सिस क्या बताता है आपका?
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी। जो आपका यह x एक्सिस है
यह कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी बताता है। एंड y एक्सिस
क्या बताता है? फ्रीक्वेंसी बताता है। यह
फ्रीक्वेंसी बताता है यह वाला। तो
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी में जब आप देखेंगे हायर
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी की तरफ जाएंगे यहां पे तो
यहां पे हायर
सिक्योरिटी रिस्क भी कई बार देखने को
मिलेंगे। एंड फ्रीक्वेंसी भी ज्यादा देखने
को मिलेगी। आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे इस
पर्टिकुलर एक्स एक्सिस कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी पे
फर्स्ट लेवल ऑफ कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी पे यहां पे
छोटा सा यहां पे सीवियरिटी का एक अटैक है।
छोटा सा सीवियरिटी का यहां बढ़ा इससे थोड़ा
बड़ा यहां जैसे ही कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी बढ़ा ये
और भी एक हाई सीवियरिटी का अटैक है यहां
पे। यहां फिलहाल कुछ भी नहीं है। यहां पे
है फिर भी एक हाई सीवियरिटी है बट थोड़ा कम
है पिछले वाले से। तो इस तरीके से जो है
ये डिफिकल्टीज एंड इस तरह की चीजें होती
है।
एक क्वेश्चन है यहां पे इट माइट बी
हेल्पफुल फॉर एवरीबॉडी डेमन इज आस्किंग
डेमन क्या बात है हेलो सर आई हैव
कंप्लीटेड द बग बंटी कोर्स शुड आई
कंटिन्यू विद बग बंटी और स्विच टू एसोसिस
एनालिस्ट ट्रेनिंग स्विच नहीं करना कुछ
नहीं छोड़ना
यह एक पार्ट है आपके साइबर सिक्योरिटी
स्किल्स का अगर आप एसओसी की तरफ जाना
चाहते हैं तो डेफिनेटली यू कैन गो विद दिस
एसओसी आप डेफिनेटली जाइए एसओसी के
इस एसओसी ट्रेनिंग के साथ जाइए। अच्छा
लगभग इतने लोग ऑनलाइन अभी लाइव हैं।
लाइक्स 300 के आसपास ही है। ऐसा क्यों है?
मुझे लगता है 300 से ज्यादा लोग लाइव आए
हुए हैं। जितने लोगों ने लाइक नहीं ठोका
होगा ना ठोक देना ताकि मजा आ जाए। फिर
इस हां तो आप अगर बग बाउंट सीख चुके हैं,
ऑलरेडी कर चुके हैं। दैट्स टोटली फाइन। गो
विथ दिस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग। आप यह
स्किल्स भी गेन कीजिए। यह ब्लू टीमिंग के
अंदर काफी हेल्प करेगा। बग बंटी आपने करी।
एक तरह से रेड टीमिंग का पार्ट आपने कवर
करा ही है। इस कोर्स के लिए नेटवर्किंग
एंड ओएस आना जरूरी है क्या? नेटवर्किंग जो
भी रिक्वायरमेंट होगी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
की वो सब मैं कराऊंगा। बेफिक्र रहिए। कोई
जरूरत नहीं आपको।
स्किल बढ़ाओ। राइट?
आपने एक कोर्स इनरोलमेंट कर दिया। अब क्या
ही कर सकते हैं?
हेलो सर। हेलो सर। आई लव टू टेक लाइव
क्लास। आई वाच्ड योर बग बंटी एंड फर्स्ट
टाइम जॉइनिंग लाइव क्लास। आई एम वेरी
हैप्पी। दैट्स ग्रेट इफ यू लव टू वॉच द
लाइव क्लासेस। एंड दैट्स ग्रेट कि आप लाइव
में आ रहे हैं। इससे ज्यादा अच्छा कुछ
नहीं हो सकता है। तो ये आपकी होती है तीन
चीजें फिशिंग, ब्रूट फ़ोर्स एंड रेंसवेयर।
अब इन तीनों चीज के साथ सबसे ज्यादा डील
करेंगे आप एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट एल1 के लिए।
इधर फोकस करना है। सभी को इधर फोकस करना
है। चैट से ज्यादा इधर फोकस कीजिए। चैट को
थोड़ी देर के लिए चैट बिल्कुल आप करना बंद
कर दीजिए। चैट में मैसेज करना बंद कर
दीजिए। और यहां फोकस कीजिए जो मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं। अब आते हैं करियर
ट्रेजजेक्टरी पे। जब करियर ट्रेजजेक्टरी
की बात कर रहे हैं ना तो कुछ इस तरीके से
सैलरी पाथ है इसका जो आपको यहां पे दिख
रहा है। कुछ इस तरीके से मतलब इट्स
इंक्रीजिंग ग्रेजुअली। यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं फर्स्ट ईयर में मतलब जब आप
एंट्री लेंगे तो आपका कुछ इस तरीके से
सैलरी पैकेज यहां पे होगा। फर्स्ट ईयर में
आपका सैलरी पैकेज यहां होगा। बीइंग एन
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट। सेकंड ईयर में आपका कुछ
यहां होगा। थर्ड ईयर में कुछ यहां होगा।
फिफ्थ ईयर में यहां होगा। फर्स्ट आपका
जीरो एंट्री लेवल पर होगा। फर्स्ट ईयर में
आप L1 प्रोफाइल पर काम कर रहे होंगे।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। सेकंड ईयर में आप L2
प्रोफाइल के लिए जाएंगे जो आपकी सैलरी को
हक करेगा। उसके बाद आप L3 या हंटर
प्रोफाइल के लिए आप यहां जाएंगे सैलरी ह
होगी। एंड देन आप मैनेजर प्रोफाइल के लिए
जाएंगे। यहां जाएंगे आप एंड सैलरी ह होगी।
सो इस तरह का ये पूरा ट्रेजेक्टरी है जो
एसओसी एनालिस्ट के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
ट्रेजजेक्टरी है। दैट्स इट। अब ये
इंटरव्यू सिनेरियोस वगैरह अह यहां पे कुछ
है यहां पे जो डिस्कस करेंगे। ठीक है?
इसको इन सिनेरियोस को बाद में देखेंगे।
अभी हमारे लिए कोई रिक्वायरमेंट इसकी नहीं
है। अब मैं यहां पे एक और चीज आता हूं
जिसको मैं यहां पे आपको बताना चाहता हूं।
मैं इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं।
हां जी। अब ये है रोड मैप। यहां पे एक और
रोड मैप है जिसको हम डील यहां पे डील करने
वाले हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है। एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट का एज अ रोल क्या होता है? इसको
थोड़ा और डीपली समझेंगे अगर। तो एज अ टिए
वन एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट यू आर द फर्स्ट
रेस्पोंडर यू मॉनिटर ट्राई एस्केलेट एंड
डॉक्यूमेंट एव्री सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट हर
सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट को आप मॉनिटर करेंगे
ट्राई करेंगे एस्केलेट करेंगे डॉक्यूमेंट
करेंगे ये आपका काम है आप मॉनिटर करेंगे
एसआईएम को ईडीआर या एसडीआर को फायर वॉल को
ईमेल अलर्ट्स को आप वैलिडेट करेंगे उन
अलर्ट्स को ट्रू पॉजिटिव है या फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है ट्रू पॉजिटिव मतलब सही है
बिल्कुल फॉल्स पॉजिटिव मतलब गड़बड़ है
एस्केलेट क्रिटिकल इवेंट्स टू टायर टू या
इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर अगर कोई क्रिटिकल
इवेंट है कोई क्रिटिकल ऐसी अलर्ट है तो
आपको एस्केलेट करना है अपने सीनियर को
आपका सीनियर कौन है एसओसी एल2 वाला उसको
आईआर को और इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर जो होते
हैं उनको लॉक एवरीथिंग इन टिकटिंग सिस्टम
और टिकटिंग सिस्टम इसीलिए होती है हर चीज
को लॉक करना है कोई भी अलॉट हो ना चाहे
कोई सा भी अलर्ट हो उसको लॉक करना ही करना
है आपको लॉग में लिखना है डालना है आपको
एंड देन केपीआई यहां पे केपीआईस का मतलब
होता है मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट एमडीीडीटी
रिस्पांस टाइम एमटी टीटीआर एक्यूरेसी
एस्केलेशन क्वालिटी ये सारी चीजें की
परफॉर्मेंस इंडेक्सेस जो होते हैं इसमें
आपको यह सारी चीजें फॉल करती हैं। बेसिकली
केपीआई का मतलब होता है की परफॉर्मेंस
इंडसेस या इंडेक्सेस जो भी आप बोल सकते
हो। तो इसमें आपको ये चीजें देखी जाती हैं
कि आपका मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट क्या है? एज
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 प्रोफाइल आप क्या आप
किस टाइम में आप डिटेक्शन कितनी जल्दी आप
किसी अलर्ट को ट्रू पॉजिटिव यानी कि एक
जेन्युइन अलर्ट की तरह फाइंड कर पाते हैं।
रिस्पांस टाइम आपका क्या है? किस तरीके से
आप रिसोंड करते हैं? रिस्पांस क्या आप
देते हैं? एंड एस्केलेशन एक्यूरेसी आपकी
क्या है? आप कितना एक्यूरेट जो है उसको
रिपोर्टिंग करते हैं? और एस्केलेशन की
क्वालिटी मतलब एस्केलेशन किस तरीके से आप
करते हैं? ये सब आपका रोल है। ये सब आपका
मेजर किया जाता है। जब आप एंटरप्राइज जब
आप कॉर्पोरेट में काम करते हैं तो इन
चीजों पे फोकस किया जाता है आपके और इन
चीजों को फोकस करके आपके जॉब को आपके रोल
को अपडेट या आपके रोल को बेसिकली अपग्रेड
किया जाता है या आपकी प्रमोशन की जाती है।
तो इनको आपको ध्यान में रखना होता है।
राइट?
राइट? टिकट मतलब हां इशू रेज़ करना ये सब
चीजें होनी। अब यहां पे सबसे रोड मैप हम
देखें थोड़ा सा। यह देखो यह जो रोड मैप है
ना यह जो मैंने आपके लिए बनाया है यह एक
बेसिक रोड मैप है। यह शॉर्ट रोड मैप है।
यह बहुत डिटेल रोड मैप नहीं है। हम इससे
बहुत ज्यादा कुछ देखने वाले हैं। तो इस पे
बस फोकस्ड मत रहिएगा। इस पे मत सर रोड मैप
में आपने बस दो-तीन चीजें बताई थी। इतना
कुछ पढ़ा रहे हो। ऐसे कैसे चलेगा सर? ऐसा
नहीं है भाई। हम रोड मैप में जो भी चीजें
बताते हैं उससे कई गुना ज्यादा देते हैं।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की यही तो खासियत है। जी।
थैंक यू। है ना?
ओके। समझ में आ गया
यार। बोल बोल के ना मेरा गला दुख जाता है।
क्या होता है कि आप लोग कुछ बोलते नहीं हो
ना तो मजा नहीं आता मुझे। अब YouTube में
कैसे कोई बोलेगा? YouTube में आप बोल नहीं
सकते। YouTube का फीचर आना चाहिए कि जो
सब्सक्राइबर्स हैं वो रिकॉर्ड कर करके बोल
सकते हैं।
सर मेरा दो कोर्स चल रहा है ऑलरेडी।
डीसीएसपी डीसीसीआई। थैंक्स फॉर दोज़
कंटेंट्स। यू आर वेलकम ब्रदर ग्लैड दैट यू
आर एंजॉयंग
[हंसी]
यस मोस्ट ऑफ़ द कंपनीज़ स्टार्ट्स विद
फ्रेशर राइट अब्सोलुटली राइट क्योंकि यस
यू आर राइट पीतांबर बिकॉज़ फ्रेशर्स के साथ
अच्छा है कि उनको ये स्किल्स गेन करने में
ज्यादा मतलब अह मज़ा भी आता है क्योंकि
अलग-अलग चीज़ उनको सीखनी है। फ्रेशर्स को
कम सैलरी भी देनी होती है। काम भी हो जाता
है। तो यस फ्रेशर्स के लिए एक अपॉर्चुनिटी
है।
आई एम फ्रॉम डीसीएपीटी कैन आई डू दिस
कोर्स एज वेल? या अब्सोलुटली यू कैन डू
एब्सोलुटली।
सर आप कांसेप्ट क्लियर कर देते हैं। बाकी
टूल्स तो खुद से भी सीख सकते हैं। क्या
बात है। ये बहुत अच्छी बात बोली यार। ये
मजा आया सुन के।
फ्रेशर की एंट्री पॉसिबल है। अरे फ्रेशर्स
की एंट्री ही पॉसिबल है। बिल्कुल पॉसिबल
है। एसओसी रोल के लिए फ्रेशर्स को
फ्रेशर्स को मतलब इंक्लूड किया जाता है।
जी हां
बेफिक्र रहने का।
थैंक यू देव। थैंक यू देवराज।
सर डस एसओसी ट्रेनिंग नीड्स नेटवर्किंग
नॉलेज? आई कैन सी यू हैव नेटवर्किंग
प्लेलिस्ट हैविंग 13 वीडियोस। इज दैट
सफिशिएंट? उन 13 वीडियोस को आप जरूर कर
लीजिएगा। बट जो भी नेटवर्किंग की
रिक्वायरमेंट होगी, जो नॉलेज होगी वो मैं
आपको बताऊंगा भी। एंड हां थोड़ी बहुत
बेसिक नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज तो चाहिए
इसमें। एंड वो मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा। उसके
लिए बेफिक्र रहिए। अदरवाइज नेटवर्किंग की
प्लेलिस्ट है। आप उसको भी फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। ठीक है? अब रोड मैप की बात करें तो
यहां पर पहला फेज आता है फाउंडेशन का जहां
पर हम इन कुछ टॉपिक्स को सीखने वाले हैं
करेंगे उनको देखेंगे देन कोर स्किल्स की
बात आती है अ जहां अंडरस्टैंड हाउ अलर्ट्स
वर्क हाउ टू ट्रैक इन्वेस्टिगेट लॉग्स
लर्न एनालिस्ट वर्क फ्लोस थिंक लाइक अ
डिफेंडर तो आपका आंसर मिल चुका होगा कई
लोगों के ये क्वेश्चन थे कि हम ये चीजें
जानेंगे क्या तो बिल्कुल कोर स्किल्स
कोर एसओसी स्किल्स में आप जानेंगे फज़ थ्री
में आता है टूल्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजीस जिसमें
जिसमें कि अलग-अलग टूल्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजीस
एसआईएम ईडीआर एक्सडीआर या mित्रे अटै अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क यानी एमआईटीआर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
जिसको आप बोलते हैं कई लोग मित्र बोलते
हैं कई लोग मित्र्रे बोलते हैं तो आप कुछ
भी बोल सकते हैं वो आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है लर्न टैक्टिक्स एंड टेक्निक्स ये सब
चीजें हम करेंगे सीखेंगे देन आती है आपकी
थ्रेड्स थ्रेट डिटेक्शन की स्टडी कॉमन
अटैक पैटर्न्स जैसे कि फिशिंग अटैक
पैटर्न्स इनके पढ़ने हैं हमें फिशिंग के
मैलवेयर रेंसवेयर ब्रूट फ़ोर्स प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन लेटरल मूवमेंट ये सब चीजें हम
देखेंगे इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस को भी हम समझ
समझेंगे अंडरस्टैंड डिटेक्शन, एस्केलेशन,
कंटेनमेंट एंड रिपोर्टिंग, लर्न व्हेन एंड
हाउ टू एस्केलेट टू एल टू और इंसिडेंट
रेस्पोंड टीम एंड देन इंटरव्यू रेडीनेस।
इंटरव्यू के लिए हम रेडी होंगे लास्ट में
सबसे लास्ट में कि जब किस तरीके से हम
इंटरव्यू के लिए प्रिपेयर हो जाएं और एल1
रोल के लिए अप्लाई करें। मैं आपको गाइड भी
करूंगा कैसे आपको अप्लाई करना है, कहां
अप्लाई करना है, इंटरव्यूज के लिए कैसे
प्रिपेयर करना है। सोचो ना एक फ्री
ट्रेनिंग में। तो ये सब मैं आपको गाइड
करूंगा। एंड आप इंटरव्यू आई होप बाय गॉड्स
ग्रेस आई होप कि अगर आप बजरंगबली ने चाह
लिया ना आपका तो आपका इंटरव्यू क्लियर हो
जाएगा। मैं गारंटी के साथ बोलता हूं बस
अपनी स्किल्स पे ट्रस्ट करो। बाकी ऊपर
वाले के ऊपर छोड़ दो। ठीक है?
जिसमें हम टेक्निकल सिनेरियो बेस्ड
क्वेश्चंस को डील करेंगे। स्टार मेथड जो
होता है बिहेवियरल आंसर्स उसको देखेंगे।
मॉक ट्रैक वॉक थ्रूज़ उनको हम करने वाले
हैं। ये सारी चीजें करेंगे। ठीक है? अब
इसमें जैसे कि सिंपल एक क्वेरी इस प्लंक
के अंदर कुछ इस तरीके की एग्जांपल क्वरी
होती है। ये चीजें अभी आपको नहीं समझ में
आएंगी। बट आप मैं चाहता हूं विजुअलाइज कर
लीजिए। देख लीजिए एक बार आगे जब आपको
दिखेगी तो आपको मजा आएगा। आगे जब आपको ये
चीजें दिखने को मिलेगी तो आपको समझ में भी
आ जाएगा। उसके बाद अटैक यूज़ केसेस में
फिशिंग, मैलवेयर एंड ब्रूटफोर्स इनको हम
मोस्टली फोकस करेंगे क्योंकि ये तीनों जो
है सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर एंड सबसे ज्यादा
दिक्कतें करती हैं हमारे एल एल1 भैया
लोगों को। राइट? एंड यहां पे करियर पाथ
में क्या होता है? करियर पाथ में यहां पे
क्या होते हैं कि पहले आपका L1 रोल होता
है। देन आपका L2 रोल होता है। देन आपका L3
रोल के लिए आप एलिजिबल होते हैं। आप तैयार
होते हैं। देन इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्ड अ
रिस्पॉन्ड जो इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्ड रोल होता
है उसके लिए आप इंसिडेंट रिसोंडर जिसको आप
बोलते हैं उसके लिए आप अह आप आपकी प्रमोशन
होती है। मतलब इस तरह ये करियर पाथ है। इस
तरीके से आप आगे बढ़ते हैं। देन आप ब्लू
टीम हंटर या थ्रेट हंटर जो है वह कहलाते
हैं। एंड आप सीनियर रोल में ऑटोमेटिकली
चले जाते हैं। ठीक है? बहुत सारे
सर्टिफिकेशंस भी इसके रिलेटेड हैं। अगर आप
जाना चाहें तो ठीक है। अदरवाइज अ मतलब ये
ब्रांड्स के अकॉर्डिंग बट मैं नहीं
बोलूंगा क्योंकि मैं आपको उस उन
सर्टिफिकेशंस में जितना सिखाएंगे उससे
ज्यादा सिखाने वाला हूं एल1 रोल के लिए।
इंडिया में सैलरी 3 से 8 लाख पर एनम वैरी
करती है। एंट्री लेवल रोल्स जो अब जब आप
एंट्री करते हैं तो सैलरी आपकी 3 से ₹8
लाख पर एनम ये जेन्युइन सैलरी मैंने आपको
यहां पे बताया हुआ है। कोई कुछ भी बोल
देता है कि भैया ट्रेनिंग आप ट्रेनिंग करो
कुछ भी बोल दिया। नहीं तो यहां पे एक
जेन्युइन सैलरी आपको मैं बता रहा हूं कि 3
से 8 लाख पर एनम का एक सैलरी स्ट्रक्चर
आपको एज अ फ्रेशर मिल जाएगा। बट जैसे ही
आप एक साल वहां पर स्पेंड कर लेते हैं और
L2 के लिए चले जाते हैं, इसमें
एक्सप्पोनेंशियल ग्रोथ आपको देखने को
मिलेगी। यू विल बी सीइंग एक्सप्पोनेंशियल
ग्रोथ फॉर दिस। इतना शानदार खतरनाक आपका
एक्सप्पोनेंशियल ग्रोथ आएगा। ये पूरी की
पूरी चीजें हैं। ठीक है? फ्रेशर्स को भी
मिलेगा भाई। फ्रेशर्स को ही मैं बोल रहा
हूं। ये फ्रेशर्स के ही बोल रहा हूं मैं।
फ्रेशर्स के नहीं भाई 8:00 बजे से सेशन
नहीं कर सकते। 8:00 पी.m. से लेट हो जाएगी
थोड़ी। 8:00 pm इज नॉट अ गुड नंबर। आठ इज
नॉट अ गुड नंबर।
ओके। आई होप कि आपको यह चीजें क्लियर अब
हो गई होंगी। अब चलिए अब हम आते हैं हमारे
पीपीटी के ऊपर में। हमारे स्लाइड्स के ऊपर
में जहां पे मैं आपको
और चीजें यहां पे एक्सप्लेन करने वाला
हूं। ठीक है? यहां पे आप समझ गए?
आपका डेली ड्यूटी क्या होगा?
आपका डेली ड्यूटी एज अ एल1 देखो आज पहला
दिन है ना? तो मैं चाहता हूं कि आप पहले
दिन में आपको सारी चीजें क्लियर कर दो
ताकि आप किसी भी तरह से कंफ्यूज ना रहगे
की क्लासेस के लिए। अदरवाइज क्या होगा?
मैं चाहता तो ये सब चीजें नहीं बताता।
स्किप कर देता मैं डायरेक्ट डायरेक्ट
प्रैक्टिकल्स पे आके टॉपिक्स पे आके आपको
बताते चलता, भागते चलता। बट उससे आप ना
इंटरव्यू लेवल की तैयारी नहीं कर सकते।
उससे आप जॉब रेडी लेवल की प्रिपरेशन नहीं
कर सकते। वो कोर्स फिर जॉब रेडी लेवल नहीं
होगी। वो कोर्स फिर टच्चा कोर्स होगा।
जैसे टूच्चे कोर्स टाइप होते हैं ना जो
ऐसे ही कुछ भी पढ़ा दिया लोगों को बुला के
वो लेवल की होगी तो टूच्चा वाला लेवल नहीं
रखना ना अपने को लेवल एक हाई लेवल एक हाई
एंड लेवल रखना है वो लेवल अटेंड करने के
लिए आप मतलब आपको थोड़ा सा चीजों को
बिल्कुल बेसिक से 390 लाइक हो चुके हैं
400 कर दो फटाफट मुझे पता है हो जाएगा अभी
मुझे पता है देखो 390 लाइक है ना मैं आपको
एक जादू दिखाता हूं मैं पांच गिनूंगा 400
हो जाएगा ठीक है पांच गिनूंगा बस
अ मतलब मैं काउंटिंग स्टार्ट कर रहा हूं।
ठीक है? एक
390 है अभी भी।
दो
अरे तीन
अ
चार
एंड लास्ट वन इज़ फाइव। लेट्स सी द लाइक्स।
अभी लाइक्स देख लेते हैं कितने लाइक्स
हैं। अपडेट अपडेटेड लाइक्स हो गए हैं। 400
398 हो चुके हैं। 400 हो गए। मुझे पता था
हो जाएंगे। आई न्यू आई न्यू दैट। हो गए
अभी 400 हो गए। 399 हो गए। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। दिस इज़ द पावर ऑफ
कम्युनिटी।
सो थैंक यू। चलिए। एज अ जूनियर सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट को ना जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट भी बोलते हैं। याद
रखिएगा। ये चीज याद रखिएगा। आपको अगर कोई
बोले जूनियर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट तो
घबराइएगा मत। एसओसी लेवल वन एनालिस्ट यू
योर वर्क इन अ 24 से एसओसी टीम एंड
मोस्टली रिव्यू द सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट्स
टुगेदर विथ योर कॉलीग्स। ड्यूरिंग योर
वर्कशिफ्ट यू विल टिपिकली मॉनिटर एंड
इन्वेस्टिगेट वेरियस सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट्स।
पार्टिसिपेट इन एसओसी ब्रेन स्टॉर्म एंड
वर्कशॉप्स। कोऑपरेट विथ अदर टीम्स टू कीप
योर कंपनी सेफ। कॉन्सेंटली लर्न एंड
डिस्कवर न्यू अटैक्स एंड डिफेंसेस। यह
आपके काम है। मॉनिटर करना। एसओसी ब्रेन
स्टार्म एंड वर्कशॉप्स में पार्टिसिपेट
करना। अदर टीम्स के साथ कोपरेट करना,
कंपनी को सेफ रखने के लिए, सिक्योर रखने
के लिए एंड कंटीन्यूअसली
सीखते रहना एंड न्यू अटैक्स एंड डिफेंस
टेक्निक्स को डिस्कवर करते रहना। चलिए अब
एज अ फ्रंट लाइन डिफेंस एज अ फर्स्ट लाइन
ऑफ़ डिफेंस यहां पे आपके जो तीन
मेजर स्टेप्स हैं वो है मॉनिटर एंड ट्रायल
अलर्ट्स। पहला है योर प्राइमरी रोल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी इज़ वाचिंग एसआईएम
डैशबोर्ड। सबसे पहले आपका पहला प्राइमरी
रोल है कि एसआईएम का डैशबोर्ड आपको देखना
है। एसआईएम बहुत खतरनाक टेक्नोलॉजी है
यार। बहुत अच्छी चीज है। एसआईएम टूल्स
काफी अच्छे-अच्छे टूल्स काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल्स हैं। जब आप एक बड़े नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में बैठे रहेंगे ना इन
टूल्स के आगे में डैशबोर्ड के ऊपर में तो
आपको अलग-अलग पैराटर्स दिखेंगे। अलग-अलग
पॉप अप अलर्ट्स आएंगे तो आपको बड़ा मजा
आएगा। अरे यार कुछ तो हो रहा है।
इन्वेस्टिगेट करने में मजा आएगा। एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट व्हेन एन अलर्ट फायर्स
यू परफॉर्म इनिशियल ट्रैक इज दिस अ रियल
थ्रेट और फॉल्स पॉजिटिव यू गैदर
कॉन्टेक्स्ट चेक लॉक्स एंड मेक द क्रिटिकल
फर्स्ट डिसीजन तो आपको पहले तो यह देखना
है कि ये एक रियल थ्रेट है या एक फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है उसके बाद एनालाइज़ एंड
डॉक्यूमेंट सेकंड स्टेप आता है फॉर ईच
अलर्ट यू एनालाइज़ रिलेवेंट लॉग्स जैसे
Windows इवेंट लॉग हो गया फायरवल लॉग्स हो
गए प्रॉक्सी लॉग्स हो गए ठीक है
आइडेंटिफाई इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज़
आईओसीज़ जिसको को बोलते हैं। मतलब एक ऐसे
इंडिकेटर्स जो कॉम्प्रोमाइज को इंडिकेट
करती हो कि हो सकता है ये कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
जाए। उन को आइडेंटिफाई करना है एंड
डॉक्यूमेंट फाइंडिंग्स क्लियरली एंड सबको
डॉक्यूमेंट करना है। क्लियर डॉक्यूमेंटेशन
करना है। ये आपका बहुत बड़ा टास्क है।
इसको आपको डेफिनेटली करना है। योर
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन हेल्प्स L2 एंड L3
एनालिस्ट्स और इंसिडेंट रेस्पोंडर्स
रेस्पोंडर्स टेक एक्शन। आपके
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन के ही बेसिस पे आपके जो
सीनियर है L2 और L3 रोल पे बैठे हैं।
इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर जो है वो आगे का
प्रोसेस करता है। सोचो ना कितनाेंट हो।
इतना इतनाेंस समझा था आपको मिलेगा। हां
हां इतनीेंस है। हां देखा बहुतेंस है।
[हंसी] बिल्कुल बताएंगे। बिल्कुल कोरी
लैंग्वेज बताएंगे। थर्ड है आपका एस्केलेट
और क्लोज। अगर आपका एनालिसिस हो चुका है
एंड आपने डिसाइड जब किया तो आपको या तो
इसको क्लोज करना है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव के तौर
पर बोलना है कि भैया यह तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
है सही नहीं है इसको क्लोज कर दो या फिर
एस्केलेट करना है डीपर इन्वेस्टिगेशन के
लिए L2 L3 या आईआर टीम को दिस डिसीजन
रिक्वायरर्स सॉलिड अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ अटैक
पैटर्न्स एंड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन रिस्क इस
डिसीजन को बनाने के लिए आपका
सॉलिड अंडरस्टैंडिंग होना चाहिए अटैक
पैटर्न्स का बिना उसके आप नहीं बना पाएंगे
डिसीजन यह डिसीजन नहीं आप क्रिएट कर
पाएंगे। इसलिए मैंने आपको बोला कि यह
एसओसीएल वन के लिए प्रिपेयर करना डीपली
घुसने के बराबर है। बस तो ये आपको कर लेना
है। दैट्स इट। ये आपको डेफिनेटली करना है।
जबरदस्त कोर्स है। थैंक यू आरव। थैंक यू।
थैंक यू वेरी मच ब्रदर।
यस। एसआई एसआईएम मतलब सिक्योरिटी इनेशन
एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट होता है। यहां पे एक
किसी बंदे ने लिखा हुआ है यहां पे जोकर
किंग ने। अ मैं जो क्वरी लिखते हैं उसका
नाम ठीक है हां क्वरी क्वरी हम एसआईएम
क्वरीज एंड इन सबके ऊपर भी डील करेंगे
उसके बेफिक्र रहना ठीक है मजा आएगा है ना
ग्रेट आई एम 10 आई एम 10 इयर्स
एक्सपीरियंस इन टेस्टिंग इज एसओसी इज़ गुड
टू चेंज द वर्क हाउ कैन आई शो एक्सपीरियंस
इन एसओसी अगर आप टेस्टिंग में हैं एसओसी
में मूव करते हैं तो आप एक्सपीरियंस को
शोकेस नहीं कर पाएंगे इवन यू आर 10 इयर्स
ऑफ एक्सपीरियंस इन टेस्टिंग आपको एज अ
फ्रेशर ही मोस्टली कंसीडर किया जाता है
क्योंकि वो पर्टिकुलर एक शिफ्टिंग ऑफ
डोमेन है आपका। फिर भी आप टेस्टिंग में अ
टेस्टिंग जब आप कर रहे हैं तो उसी में आप
उसी टाइम में जॉब के जॉब में ही जब आप
टेस्टिंग वाले जॉब में हैं एसआईएम के
कांसेप्ट्स को सीख लीजिए या एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट के जो भी रिक्वायरमेंट्स हैं
जैसे आपकी ये ट्रेनिंग हो रही है या जो भी
आपके टॉपिक्स हैं उसको सीखते चलिए और उस
पे प्रैक्टिस हैंड्स ऑन भी कीजिए और अपने
अभी करंट कंपनी के अंदर में ना आप एसओसी
लेवल वाले वर्क भी उनसे करने को देने को
बोलिए आप खुद को कि मुझे ये भी वर्क चाहिए
थोड़ी बहुत मुझे इस पे वर्क करनी
एंड उनसे ट्राई कीजिए कि जब आप उसको कंपनी
को लीव करें तो एज अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट के
रोल पे लीव करने की कोशिश कीजिए। कंपनी से
एक्सपीरियंस लेटर लीजिए। उनसे एसओसी
एनालिस्ट पे का भी वहां पे मेंशन कराइए।
अगर वो हो जाता है तो आपका वो एक्सपीरियंस
काउंट हो जाएगा और आपके 10 साल बर्बाद
नहीं होंगे। बस आई होप आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा। राइट?
राहिल कुमार आई होप यू गॉट योर आंसर।
एसआईएम का फुल फॉर्म पूछ रहे हैं मानस
मानस यू आर आस्किंग एसआईएम का फुल फॉर्म
आप वैसे Google कर लीजिएगा पता चल जाएगा।
सिक्योरिटी इंफॉर्मेशन एंड इवेंट
मैनेजमेंट होता है। आप Google कर लीजिएगा
वैसे आपको पता चल जाएगा।
नेक्स्ट क्लास का टॉपिक क्या है? हम
Google करके आएंगे। हम रिसर्च करके आएंगे।
ये तो मैं नहीं बताऊंगा। ये तो यही तो
सीक्रेट रहने वाली है। [हंसी]
ओके हेलो डिफ्रॉिस एकडमी। गुड इवनिंग।
हेलो निषार्क कैसे हो ब्रदर? गुड इवनिंग
टू यू। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
हां जी। ये ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट होगी। डीएई
की भी कंप्लीट होगी। अभी डीएचई में थोड़ा
टाइम लग गया। जो ट्रेनर है आपके सचिन सर
उनके साथ कुछ इशू हुआ था जिसकी वजह से
थोड़ा सा गैप आ गया। अभी वो भी कंप्लीट
होगी। अब आइए यहां पे नाउ लेट्स कम हियर।
एल वन एनालिस्ट्स आर द गेटकीपर्स। यू फ़्टर
नॉइज़ फ्रॉम रियल थ्रेट्स। L1 एनालिस्ट गेट
कीपर्स होते हैं भैया। समझ लीजिए। व्हाइल
व्ह वाइल्स L2 एनालिस्ट्स परफॉर्म डीप
ड्राइव इन्वेस्टिगेशंस। L2 जब आपका
प्रमोशन होगा L2 में तो आप डीप ड्राइव
इन्वेस्टिगेशंस भी करना सीखेंगे। एंड L3
हैंडल्स एडवांस थ्रेट्स एडवांस थ्रेट
हंटिंग। थ्रेट हंटिंग L3 के तरफ L3 हैंडल
करता है। योर रोल एश्यर्स नो लेजिटमेट
थ्रेट स्लिप्स थ्रू अननोटिस्ड। आपका रोल
ये असोर करता है कि कोई भी थ्रेट जो है
कोई भी जो थ्रेट है वो अननोटिस्ड ना रह
जाए। कहीं से घुस ना जाए, कहीं पे अटैक ना
हो जाए। शिफ्ट्स आर टिपिकली 8 टू 12 आवर्स
इन 24 * 7 रोटेशन रिक्वायरिंग कॉन्स्टेंट
विजिलेंस एंड क्विक थिंकिंग। शिफ्ट्स वाइज
होते हैं ये। ठीक है?
क्योंकि देखो इतने इतने इसमें रोल्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट क्यों होती है? आपको समझना
चाहिए। एक कंपनी में मल्टीपल एल1 काम कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि ये शिफ्ट वाइज जॉब है
आपकी। अब देखो एक ही बंदा 24 * 7 तो काम
नहीं करेगा। तो कंपनी में दो तीन बंदे
रिक्वायरमेंट चाहिए। एक शिफ्ट खत्म होगी
दूसरा शिफ्ट चालू होगा दूसरे बंदे की।
क्योंकि इसकी मॉनिटरिंग 24 * 7 चाहिए। यह
24 * 7 मॉनिटर होता है। इसको छोड़ नहीं
सकते। छोड़ेंगे पता चलेगा बहुत बड़ा बेड़ा
गर्क हो जाएगा। अब देखिए रोड मैप एक
लर्निंग रोड मैप मैंने जो डिजाइन किया
आपके लिए वो रोड मैप आपको समझा देता हूं
यहां पे। इस रोड मैप से आपका बहुत कुछ
क्लियर हो जाएगा कि हम क्या-क्या चीजें
करने वाले हैं। अब ये जो रोड मैप है ये
वैसे तो फोर टू 5 मंथ्स का रोड मैप है। बट
ये हम 3 मंथ्स में कवर कर सकते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं होगी। सारी चीजें कवर कर
सकते हैं। थ्री टू 3.5 मंथ्स मान के चलो।
थोड़ा ऊपर नीचे होगा यार तो उतना माइंड
नहीं करना है आपको। ठीक है? पहले फेज में
फाउंडेशन फेज है हमारा जिसमें कि हम
नेटवर्किंग के कुछ कांसेप्ट्स को कवर
करेंगे। अब यह जो फेज वाइज मैंने यहां पे
मेंशन किया है बनाया है यह आपके
मतलब आपके लिए बनाया है मैंने आपको दिखाने
के लिए ताकि आपको ईजीली समझ में आ जाए।
मैं अपने अकॉर्डिंग कराऊंगा। ये सारे
फेजेस बस कंप्लीट करूंगा मैं बट अपने
अकॉर्डिंग करूंगा। जरूरी नहीं है कि मैं
फेज वन पहले करा के फेज टू, फेज थ्री ऐसे
कराऊंगा। इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड बट यह सारे
फेजेस कंप्लीट अपने होंगे। दैट्स इट।
हेलो नितेश सर, हाउ आर यू? आई एम गुड। आई
एम गुड। समझ में आ गया? सही है ना? यह फेज
व फेज टू में कोर एसोसिएट स्किल्स को हम
कवर करेंगे। जैसे कि लॉग एनालिसिस हो गया,
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट्स को, इंसिडेंस को समझना
हो गया, अलर्ट ट्रैक मेथोडोलॉजीस हो गए।
फिर फज़ थ्री में हम टूल्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजीज़
के ऊपर आएंगे। जैसे एसआईएम प्लेटफॉर्म्स
स्प्लंक हो गया, सेंटिनल हो गए, इडीआर
कॉनंसेप्ट्स पे आएंगे। ठीक है? मथ थ्रे
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क या एमआईटीआर फ्रेमवर्क्स
पे आएंगे। इंटरव्यूअर्स अह इसमें आपका
क्या एक्सपेक्ट करेंगे कि रियल
एक्सपीरियंस विथ एटलीस्ट वन एसआईएम इवन इफ
अह थ्रू फ्री ट्रायल्स और होम लैब्स।
इंटरव्यूअर हमेशा चाहता है कि एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आप कम से कम रियल
एक्सपर्टीज लेकर आ किसी भी एक एसआईएम टूल
पे। कोई सा भी टूल हो सकता है। चाहे आप
ट्रायल वर्जन उसका यूज़ करके आ चाहे आप
उसका कोई होम लैब्स कहीं से आप करके आ बट
आपको रियल एक्सपीरियंस होना चाहिए। तो
आपका वो कंसीडर हो जाएगा। मैं बताऊंगा
आपको कैसे करना है, कैसे लेना है वो सब।
सारे सेशंस में आप रहेंगे तो आपको सब पता
चलेगा। फेज फोर में थ्रेड डिटेक्शंस जहां
पे कॉमन अटैक्स फ्रॉम डिफेंडर्स
पर्सपेक्टिव हम देखेंगे जैसे फिशिंग,
मैलवेयर, ब्रूड फोर्स, लैटरल मूवमेंट ये
सारी चीजें उसको समझेंगे। देन फेज फाइव
आएगा आपका इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस का,
अंडरस्टैंडिंग, इंसिडेंट लाइफ साइकिल,
कंटेनमेंट स्ट्रेटजीस, एविडेंस,
प्रिजर्वेशन ये सब चीजें हम देखेंगे। जहां
पे इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस वाला हमारा फज़ आएगा।
इन फेज को भी आप यहां पे आप पढ़ के देख
सकते हैं। आप इन टॉप इसको पढ़ भी सकते हैं
कि एग्जैक्टली क्या-क्या है। मैं इतना अभी
डीप इन टॉपिक्स को एक्सप्लेन नहीं करूंगा
क्योंकि हम एक-एक फेज को ना बहुत डिटेल
में सीखने वाले हैं। तो मैं इन टॉपिक्स पे
अभी ज्यादा फोकस इसलिए नहीं कर रहा
क्योंकि हम एक-एक टॉपिक को उठा उठा के
पटकने वाले हैं। एक-एक टॉपिक को बहुत
थॉरली डील करने वाले हैं। फेज सिक्स हमारा
इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन जो कि हमारा लास्ट फेज
होगा इस पूरे कोर्स का जहां पे मैं आपको
इंटरव्यू के लिए प्रिपेयर कराऊंगा। दैट्स
इट। कैसा लगा यह फेज? मुझे बताइए यह फेज
कैसे लगे आपको?
लेट मी नो। इस फेज में मैं आपको जब डिलीवर
करूंगा तो कितना मजा आएगा? कैसा लगा आपको?
बताइए।
थोड़ा जानकारी ले लूं मैं।
लेट
[हंसी] एक ने
एक ने कमेंट किया है। वर्ल्ड गेमिंग कल्चर
इन्होंने कमेंट किया है। इनके कमेंट्स
मैंने मेरे को मैं मेरे को पढ़ के मजा आ
गया। हंसी भी आई मुझे। हंसी प्राउड वाली
हंसी है। डिफ्रॉनिक्स एक ट्रैप है। अगर
कोई एक बार इनसे सीखने लग जाए तो वो कहीं
और नहीं जाएगा क्योंकि इतना बढ़िया नॉलेज
किसी और के पास नहीं है।
[हंसी]
वर्ल्ड गेमिंग कल्चर आप जो भी हैं थैंक यू
वेरी मच ऑन स्पीकिंग ऑन बिहाफ ऑफ
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एंड आई एम ग्लैड कि आपको काफी
अच्छा लग रहा है एंड आप इस तरीके की थॉट्स
रखते हैं हमारे लिए मैं चाहता हूं हर
लर्नर हर स्टूडेंट हर प्रोफेशनल के दिमाग
में ऐसी थॉट आ जाए अगर हमारे लिए तो इससे
बड़ी बात हमारे लिए कुछ नहीं हो सकती है
अच्छा अच्छा बोला ट्रैप है सही है भाई सही
है ट्रैप है बोल के मतलब तारीफ कर दी क्या
बात बात है।
एकदम मस्त है। बढ़िया।
हरमित बोल रहे हैं, "सर, आई हैव क्लियर्ड
ईजीपीटी वाया योर डीईएचई कोर्स।" आई एम
आल्सो लर्निंग बग बंटी बाय रेफरिंग टू योर
वीडियोस साइड बाय साइड। नाउ आई एम गेयरिंग
फॉर एसओसीएल वन फ्रॉम योर वीडियोस। होप टू
गेट जॉब एज एसओसीएल वन। अ या हरमित
आई होप आप एसओसी एल1 के लिए जॉब लैंड कर
जाए। आई होप द सेम एंड विश यू ऑल द बेस्ट।
आप इसको कंटिन्यू कीजिए। लाइव कोशिश
कीजिएगा आने का।
सर 3 महीने में करवा देना जॉब स्विच करनी
है। ओके राहिल बिल्कुल श्योरली। क्या बात
है। [हंसी]
थैंक यू।
चलिए थैंक्स थैंक्स
नहीं नोट्स कौन से नोट्स ये पीपीटी जो बात
कर रहे हो पीपीटी की बात कर रहे हो चलो
अगर आपको पीपीटी चाहिए तो मैं ट्राई
करूंगा आपको प्रोवाइड करने की ठीक है
लव फ्रॉम बिहार
लव यू सर लव यू ब्रदर
या
वजू देखेंगे वजू भी देखेंगे सॉरी अब आ
जाइए अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट पे अटैक
सिनेरियोस डिफेंडर्स पर्सपेक्टिव से इसको
देख लेते हैं देखो अंडरस्टैंडिंग अटैक्स
फ्रॉम द एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट व्यू पॉइंट मींस
फोकसिंग ऑन डिटेक्शन नॉट एक्सप्लइटेशन
आपको एक्सप्लइट नहीं करना है। एज एसोसिएशन
एनर्लिस्ट आपको डिटेक्शन पे फोकस करना है।
डिफेंस पे फोकस करना है। आप रेड टीमर यहां
नहीं है। यू आर अ ब्लू टीमर। डिफेंसिव
जोश-जश में आके
भावनाओं में बह के अटैक मत करने लग जाना।
कहीं पे एस एज अ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट मार के
भगा दिए जाओगे कंपनी से। समझ में आ रहा
है? अटैक नहीं करना है भाई। डिफेंड करना
है। फॉर ईच अटैक टाइप यू नीड टू नो व्हाट
लॉग्स अपीयर व्हिच अलर्ट्स फायर एंड योर
इमीडिएट रिस्पांस स्टेप्स। हियर आर द
मोस्ट क्रिटिकल अटैक पैटर्न्स यू विल
एनकाउंटर ऑन शिफ्ट। तो आपको यह देखना है
कि क्या लॉग आ रहे हैं। किस तरह का अलर्ट
मिला है आपको? क्या इमीडिएट रिस्पांस आपके
तरफ से होगा। स्टेप्स होंगे ये सब देखना
है। फिशिंग अटैक व्हाट एसओसी सीज़? एसओसी
एज अ एसओसी आप क्या सीख देखेंगे? ईमेल
गेटवे अलर्ट्स। यूजर क्लिकिंग सस्िशियस
लिंक्स। आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन टू न्यूली
रजिस्टर्ड डोमेन। आपका एक्शन क्या होगा?
चेक ईमेल हेडर्स वेरीफाई डोमेन रेपुटीशन।
आइसोलेट यूजर एंड पॉइंट्स। इफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सस्पेक्टेड यह आपका काम
होगा। तो यह एक एग्जांपल के तौर पे मैं
बता रहा हूं कि अगर एक फिशिंग अटैक होता
है एज अ फिशिंग एक फिशिंग अटैक की तरह
मतलब आप फिशिंग अटैक अगर देख रहे हैं कहीं
पे किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पे तो यहां पे एज
एसओसी आप क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं?
मतलब आप एसओसी क्या-क्या चीजें आपको
दिखेंगी और आपको एल1 मतलब एसओसी
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर क्या देखेगा और
एज अ एनालिस्ट आप क्या करेंगे? मैल
एग्जीक्यूशन जब होगा तो आपका एसओसी
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर क्या देखेगा?
एडीआर अलर्ट ऑन सस्िशियस प्रोसेस। एडीआर
का अलर्ट आएगा सस् प्रोसेस पे। अनसाइन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स ऐसे एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स जो
साइन नहीं है जो ऑथराइज नहीं है वो आपको
दिखेंगे। आउटबाउंड बेकन टू C2 सर्वर कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर पे आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन
दिखेंगे। एंड आप एज अ एल1 क्या करेंगे?
क्वारेंटाइन कर देंगे फाइल को। वायरस टोटल
पे#श के#श को चेक करेंगे। आईओसी
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज उसको
डॉक्यूमेंट करेंगे कि कॉम्प्रोमाइज के
क्या-क्या इंडिकेटर्स हैं। एस्केलेट फॉर
फॉरेंसिक्स एंड एस्केलेट कर देंगे अपने
सीनियर भैया लोगों के पास दीदी लोगों के
पास कि भैया दीदी बहुत बड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्स
दिक्कत है। एस्केलेट जाओ आपका एक बेनिफिट
भी है। पता है एज अ एलोन बेनिफिट भी है।
अगर आप कंफर्म कर चुके हैं कि एक अलर्ट
है। एकशियस एक्टिविटी है। ज्यादा टेंशन
नहीं लेना है आपको।
एस्केलेट मार दो। बहुत लोग करते हैं ये सब
बहुत ये बहुत चोचले हैं ये करते हैं
एस्केलेट अरे सर बहुत बड़ा प्रॉब्लम लगा
मुझे यह तो दिक्कत हो जाती है नेटवर्क की
बैंड बज जाती है एस्केलेट कर दिया आप देखो
करो बेचारे सीनियर्स परेशान रहते हैं आपके
आपके जैसे एल1 के एस्केलेशंस से
बड़ी बड़ी बड़ी डांट खाने को भी मिलती है
भाई एल1 वालों को याद रखना बट उसको
पॉजिटिवली लो ग्रेसफुली लो और अपनी नॉलेज
को बढ़ाओ
ठीक है रैंसमवेयर
रैंसमवेयर में व्हाट एसओसी मास फाइल
इंक्रिप्शन जब रैंसमवेयर होगा तो
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर जो पूरा डैशबोर्ड
या मतलब बेसिकली जो ऑपरेशन सेंटर है क्या
वो उसको क्या दिखेगा फाइल इंक्रिप्शन हो
रही है रैंसम नोट्स आ रहे हैं अनयूजुअल
डिस्क एक्टिविटी हो रही है बैकअप्स डिलीट
करने की कोशिश की जा रही है डेटा की तो
एल1 क्या करेगा इमीडिएट एस्केलेशन क्योंकि
यह बहुत बड़ा क्रिटिकल वाली चीज है तो एल1
के बस की एल1 बोलेगा इस पे ज्यादा नहीं
सोचना। एस्केलेट सीनियर रैंसवेयर देखो
आइसोलेट अफेक्टेड सिस्टम अफेक्टेड
सिस्टम्स को हटा देना। सारी चीजों की
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करना उसकी टाइमलाइन के
अकॉर्डिंग एंड इंसिडेंट रिसोंड टीम को
तुरंत फटाफट बताना। सर आपने देखा मूवी
हेलो अटैक डिटेक्टेड। हेलो अटैक हुआ है
भैया। जल्दी कुछ करो। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स एसओसी
क्या देखेगा? मल्टीपल फेल्ड लॉग इन
अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं। अकाउंट लॉकआउट्स
लॉक्स हो रहे हैं। अनयूजुअल लोकेशनेशंस
अनयूजुअल आईपी से जो है एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश की जा रही है। तो एल1 क्या करेगा?
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 ये वेरीफाई करेगा
यूज़र्स की एक्टिविटी को। लेज लेजिटमेट है
या नहीं है। फालतू के आईपीस को ब्लॉक कर
देगा। जो भी फालतू के ऐसे मल्टीपल ट्राई
हो रहे हैं किसी आईपी से सस्िशियस आईपी
उसको ब्लॉक कर देगा। अनसक्सेसफुल या
सक्सेसफुल कॉम्प्रोमाइज। बेसिकली
सक्सेसफुल कॉम्प्रोमाइज को चेक करेगा।
अनसक्सेसफुल भी कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ उसको भी
चेक करेगा। एंड क्रेडेंशियल्स को रिसेट
करेगा अगर जरूरत पड़ती है कि कि भैया ना
अब इसको रिसेट कर दो। यह भी काम करेगा।
उसके बाद यहां पे आपका आता है अलर्ट
ट्रायग योर डिसीजन मेकिंग फ्रेमवर्क। अब
सबसे एव्री एसोसिएट शिफ्ट प्रेजेंस डजंस
और 100्स ऑफ़ अलर्ट्स। बहुत सारे अलर्ट्स
आते हैं। योर स्किल लाइज़ इन रैपिडली
डिटरमाइनिंग व्हिच रिक्वायर्स एस्कलेशन
व्हिच आर फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। अब आपका स्किल ही
डिफाइन करता है कि कौन सी स्किल जो आपकी
अलर्ट है उसको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव बताना है कि
डिटेक्ट कर लेना है कि फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है
और कौन सी ऐसी है जिसको एस्केलेट करने की
जरूरत है यानी कि वो पॉजिटिव है एंड
पॉजिटिव मतलब कि ये अटैक मतलब अलर्ट एंड
उसको एस्केलेट करने की जरूरत पड़ रही है।
दिस सिस्टेटिक अप्रोच इंश्योर यू नेवर मिस
रियल थ्रेट्स व्हाइल अवॉयडिंग अलर्ट फैटिक
यह फॉलो दिस फ्रेमवर्क फॉर एव्री सिंगल
अलर्ट। ये फ्रेमवर्क आप फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
चार चीजें हैं। इनिशियल असेसमेंट, लॉग
एनालिसिस, कॉन्टेक्स्ट गैदरिंग एंड
डिसीजन। पहले रीड अलर्ट डिस्क्रिप्शन। जो
भी अलर्ट आ रहा है उसको पढ़िए। चेक
सीवियरिटी रेटिंग्स। उसकी सीवियरिटी को
चेक कीजिए। नोट अफेक्टेड एसेट्स। जो भी
एसेट्स अफेक्टेड हुए हैं उसके वजह से उसको
नोट कीजिए। क्विक कॉन्टेक्स्ट में क्या
है? इज़ दिस अ क्रिटिकल सर्वर और यूजर वर्क
स्टेशन? बिज़नेस आवर्स और 3 am? मतलब यह एक
क्रिटिकल सर्वर है तो आपको तुरंत आपको
एक्ट करना होगा या फिर यूजर वर्क स्टेशन
है चलेगा। थोड़ा बहुत ढीला भी हो तो
चलेगा। बिजनेस आवर के टाइम में हो रहा है
तो यह बहुत बड़ा अ प्रॉब्लम नहीं हो सकता
है क्योंकि बिज़नेस आवर में सभी एक्टिव
रहेंगे। एंड यह तुरंत के तुरंत जो है आपको
रिस्पांस मिलेगा बिज़नेस आवर के टाइम पे।
एंड अगर आप रात के देर रात या बिज़नेस आवर
नहीं है। 2:00 बजे 3:00 बजे रात को कुछ हो
रहा है तो उस समय दिक्कत तो होगी। घंटी तो
बजेगी। तब आती है लॉग एनालिसिस। क्वेरी
एसआईएम फॉर रिलेटेड लॉग्स। एसआईएम को आपको
क्वेरी करना है लॉग्स के लिए। चेक 30
मिनट्स बिफोर एंड आफ्टर अलर्ट। अलर्ट के
30 मिनट्स पहले एंड बाद के लॉग्स को आपको
देखना है। जिससे कि आपको एक क्लियर पिक्चर
मिलेगा कि एग्जैक्टली क्या हुआ है। लुक
फॉर क्या देखना है आपको? सोर्स आईपी,
डेस्टिनेशन, यूजर अकाउंट्स, प्रोसेस
डिलेज़, डिटेल्स, फ्रीक्वेंसीज ये सब आपको
पैराटर्स को ध्यान रखना है। हालांकि इसके
अलावा भी पैराटर्स होते हैं। बट अभी ये
एग्जांपल के तौर पे बता रहा हूं।
सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
हां जी हम एक दूसरे से कन्वर्सेशन भी
करेंगे अभी जब जैसे ही अब ये खत्म होने
वाला है तो हम एक दूसरे से बातें भी
करेंगे थोड़ी कॉन्टेक्स्ट गैदरिंग इज
सोर्स आईपी इंटरनल और एक्सटर्नल जो सोर्स
आईपी है वो इंटरनल है कि एक्सटर्नल है
एक्सटर्नल है तब तो कोई बात नहीं चलो बाहर
से अटैक हो रहा है इंटरनल है मतलब
चोर की दाढ़ी में तिनका और मतलब कि हम
क्या एक कहावत है ना कि अ
ऐसे ऐसे कोई एक कहावत है कि
छोरा बगल में छोरा और शहर में ढिढोरा तो
वही यहां पे अगर इंटरनल आईपी आती है तो
वही वाली कहावत हो जाएगी कि बगल में छोरा
एंड शहर में ढिढोरा नमक हलाली जिसका नमक
खाया उसी से नमक हलाली कर ली जिस थाली में
खाया उसी थाली में छेद कर दिया इंटरनल
आईपी है तो मतलब इंटरनल सीक्रेट
एजेंट लगाओ उसके पीछे इज़ यूजर अकाउंट
लेजिटमेट? क्या यूजर का अकाउंट लेजिटमेट
है? चेक थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस नोन मलिशियस
डोमेन आईपी एनी सिमिलर अलर्ट्स रिसेंटली।
तो आपको चेक करना है थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस में
क्या है? मलिशियस डोमेन आईपी चेक करनी है
आपको। सिमिलर अलर्ट्स रिसेंटली कभी आपको
मिले थे क्या? उसको आपको चेक करना है। एंड
देन आती है सबसे हार्ड पार्ट डिसीजन
मेकिंग। डिसीजन मेकिंग वाला पार्ट बहुत
हार्ड है भाई। बहुत हार्ड। क्योंकि ट्रू
पॉजिटिव है। पॉजिटिव है आपका। तो एस्केलेट
कर लीजिए। डॉक्यूमेंट डॉक्यूमेंटेशन के
साथ एस्केलेट करना है आपके सीनियर्स को।
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है। क्लोज कर दीजिए क्लियर
जस्टिफिकेशन के साथ। जब आप क्लोज भी
करेंगे तब भी आपको डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करना है।
वहां पे जस्टिफिकेशन देनी है आपको कि आपने
इस अलर्ट को क्यों क्लोज करा? क्यों आपको
लगा कि ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है। ये फॉल्स एक
अलर्ट है। तो डिटेल में बतानी पड़ती है।
कहीं आपने किसी एक जेन्युइन अलर्ट को
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव बाय मिस्टेक समझ के क्लोज
कर दिया। जस्टिफिकेशन में भी डाल दिया। और
उसकी वजह से फ्यूचर में कोई प्रॉब्लम आ
जाती है नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर
तो आपके ऊपर पहाड़ टूटने वाला है। भाई याद
रखिएगा आपके ऊपर सीनियर्स का सुपर
सीनियर्स का पहाड़ टूट जाएगा। ऐसे पकड़ के
ना आपको ऐसी पिटाई लगाएंगे कि आप सोच भी
नहीं सकते। मतलब थप्पड़ थप्पड़ नहीं
पड़ेगी लेकिन उसके अलावा सब हो जाएगा। सोच
लो क्योंकि एक पूरे इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर की
सिक्योरिटी कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाएगी उससे।
आपके एक छोटे से मिस्टेक से तो बहुत
चैलेंजिंग वर्क भी है ये। मजा इसीलिए आता
है लोगों चैलेंजिंग वर्क है।
बैंड तो बज जाएगी। हां। अब देखो ट्रू
पॉजिटिव इंडिकेटर्स क्या होते हैं? जब भी
कोई अलर्ट आती है तो पॉजिटिव इंडिकेटर्स
क्या होते हैं? और फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स किस
तरह के होते हैं? वो मैं डील कर देता हूं।
आपको थोड़ा क्लेरिटी मिल जाएगी।
कनेक्शन टू नॉन मैलिसियस आईपी डोमेन। अगर
कोई कनेक्शन ऐसी बनी है नॉन मैिस एक
मलिशियस आईपी डोमेन जो नोन है तो वहां पर
यह पॉजिटिव इंडिकेटर है। अनयूजुअल टाइम ऑफ
एक्टिविटी रात के 2 3:00 बजे ऐसा कुछ
एक्टिविटी हो रहा है। इसका मतलब कुछ तो
गड़बड़ है। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन अटेमप्ट्स
नॉर्मल यूजर है कोई एस्केलेट करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है बार-बार। रूट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बनने की कोशिश कर रहा है।
यह भी एक इंडिकेटर है। डेटा एक्स
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन पैटर्न्स लार्ज अपलोड्स टू
क्लाउड स्टोरेज। अब कोई है जो बहुत बड़े
लेवल पे क्लाउड में स्टोरेज क्लाउड में
अपलोड्स कर रहा है डेटा को
डेटा डाउनलोड कर रहा है कहीं से बहुत
ज्यादा मतलब डेटा एक्स एक्सिल्टरेट होने
वाली है मल्टीपल फेल्ड लॉग इन फॉललोड बाय
सक्सेस बहुत मल्टीपल लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स हो
रहे हैं एंड सक्सेसफुल भी हुए हैं उसमें
से कई लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स ये भी बहुत बड़ा
पॉजिटिव इंडिकेटर है दैट्स इट इनाइडर
इनाइडर
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया फॉल्स पॉ
पॉजिटिव्स क्या-क्या हो सकते हैं?
ऑटोमेटेड सिस्टम स्कैन्स ट्रिगर ट्रिगरिंग
पोर्ट पोर्ट स्कैन अलर्ट्स। अब ऐसे
ऑटोमेटेड सिस्टम स्कैन्स हो रहे हैं जो कि
पोर्ट स्कैन के अलर्ट्स को ट्रिगर कर दे
रहा है। मतलब पोर्ट स्कैनिंग हो रही है
उसको ट्रिगर कर दे रहे हैं। तो ये फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स में आ सकते हैं। लेजिटमेट एडमिन
एक्टिविटी फ्लैग्ड एज सस्िशियस। अब कोई
एडमिन है भैया आपके पास सारी डिटेल्स सारी
ऑथॉरिटी है और आपकी ही एक्टिविटी को फ्लैग
कर दिया जाए सस्पिशियस एक्टिविटी। तो यह
फ़ॉल्स पॉज़िटिव है। पुअरली ट्यून एसआईएम
रूल्स विथ लो थ्रेशहोल्ड्स। अब कोई एसआईएम
रूल ऐसी बनी है जो एकदम पुअर रूल्स हैं
जिसमें प्रॉपर रूल्स मेंशन नहीं है। तो यह
भी आपका फॉल्स पॉजिटिव लेकर दे सकता है।
सॉफ्टवेयर ट्रिगरिंग ईडीआर हरिस्टिक्स।
मतलब कि ऐसे कोई सॉफ्टवेयर्स जो ईडीआर
हरिस्टिक्स को ट्रिगर कर रहे हैं। मतलब
जैसे कि अब ईडीआर बनी है अलर्ट देने के
लिए डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट्स
एंड मतलब प्रॉपर जो एक रूल्स के अकॉर्डिंग
अलर्ट्स जो अ बेसिकली रूल्स के अकॉर्डिंग
जो अलर्ट्स ना दे और ऐसे ही कुछ भी अलर्ट
अगर दे दे रही है आपको तो वो भी फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स में आपकी कंसीडर हो जाएगी।
शेड्यूल्ड टास्क अपीयरिंग एज अनयू
प्रोसेससेस। अब कोई टास्क है शेड्यूल्ड
है। लोगों ने किया है आपकी आप ही के लोगों
ने आप ही के टीम ने और उसको भी अनयूजुअल
प्रोसेस बता रहे हैं। तो ये भी फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है भाई। सिंपल दैट्स इट। अब यहां
पे जब इंटरव्यूज वगैरह में हम इंटरव्यू
वाली चीजें करेंगे तो उसमें हमारे पास
मल्टीपल क्वेश्चंस आएंगे। तो ये भी हम
देखेंगे। हालांकि ये अभी मैं एक एग्जांपल
के लिए मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं ताकि
आपको मजा आए। देखो मान लो एक क्वेश्चन
आपसे पूछता है इंटरव्यूअर यू रिसीव एन
अलर्ट फॉर 50 फेल्ड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स
व्हाट डू यू डू? तो इसका एक आंसर है आई
वुड एस्केलेट इट। यह पुअर आंसर है। मतलब
फालतू आंसर है कि मैं इसको एस्केलेट कर
दूंगा। 50 लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट हुए हैं फेल्ड
वाले। मैं इसको एस्केलेट कर दूंगा भैया।
ऐसा
स्ट्रांग आंसर क्या है? फर्स्ट आई वुड चेक
द टाइम फ्रेम। 50 अटेम्प्ट्स इन 1 मिनट
सजेस्ट ऑटोमेटेड ब्रूट फ़ोर्स। ब्रूटफोर्स
को यह ऑटोमेट मतलब एक ऑटोमेटेड ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स लग रहा है क्योंकि 50 अटेम्प्ट्स 1
मिनट में हुए हैं। व्हाइल 50 ओवर 24 आवर्स
माइट बी अ लेजिटमेट यूजर विद पासवर्ड
इशूज़। अगर कोई 50 अटैक 50 अटेम्प्ट्स हुए
हैं 24 घंटे में हुए हैं तो हो सकता है
कोई लेजिटमेट यूजर हो जो मल्टीपल टाइम
पासवर्ड रिकवर या पासवर्ड का इशू आ रहा हो
वो कर रहा हो। आई वुड वेरीफाई द सोर्स
आईपी इज़ द इंटरनल और एक्सटर्नल चेक
रेपुटेशन रिव्यू एनी इफ एनी अटेम्प्ट
सक्सीडेड। ठीक है? कोई अटेम्प्ट सक्सेस तो
हुआ है क्या? चेक फॉर सिमिलर एक्टिविटी
अगेंस्ट अदर अकाउंट्स। अगर इंटरनल आईपी है
हो सकता है किसी यूजर की हो। सक्सेस भी हो
गया इसका मतलब हो सकता है वो जेन्युइन
यूजर है। तभी तो सक्सेस हो गया है। ऐसा भी
हो सकता है कि कोई इंसाइडर हो। फ्रॉड
फ्रॉड हो बंदा बैठा हो। तो यह सारी चीजें
इस तरीके से आंसर देना होता है। यह आंसर्स
एंड इन सब पर जब हम इंटरव्यू वाली
प्रिपरेशन करेंगे तो उसमें पूरी डीपली हम
इसी तरीके से कवर करेंगे कि एक पुअर आंसर
क्या हो सकता है और एक आप परफेक्ट एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल1 जब आप बन जाएंगे तो आपको किस
तरीके से आंसर करना है? तो ये एक प्रॉपर
स्ट्रांग आंसर क्या होगा? इस तरीके से हम
समझेंगे। समझ में आ रहा है? समझ में आ रहा
है कि यह कितना खतरनाक होने वाला है यह
ट्रेनिंग? इंटरव्यूज की प्रिपरेशन आपकी
किस लेवल की होगी? जब आप ऐसे आंसर करोगे
ना तो इंटरव्यूअर ऐसे मुंह खोलेगा। अच्छा
पूछेगा आपसे कहां से सीखा? कहां से पढ़ा
आपने? कौन सी सर्टिफिकेशन करी? अरे भैया
मैंने कोई फैंसी सर्टिफिकेशन बड़े से बड़े
सर्टिफिकेशन नहीं कर रहे हैं। हम तो बस
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी वाले हैं। थोड़े खोल
लेते हैं। चैनल उस पे एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग
चल रही थी। हमने कर लिया ट्रेनिंग को। बस
हम उसके लिए प्रिपेयर हो गए। बस हो गया।
यही तो किया हमने और तो कुछ कर नहीं।
इंटरव्यू बोलेगा कि हैं डिफ्रॉनिस एकेडमी
ये कौन है भाई? ये कहां कहां से सीखा है?
अरे सर आप भी जाओ आप भी देख लो। आप भी सीख
लो। अगली बार से उसी तरीके से आंसर जो हम
करेंगे उसको उसी तरीके से प्रोसेस कर
लेना। क्वेश्चन भी वैसे ही कर लेना। बस
सिंपल सा फंडा है। बस यही करना है आपको।
और तो कुछ करना नहीं है। डेफ्रॉनिक्स
डिफ्रॉनिक्स। चलिए
अब यहां पे एसेंशियल टूल्स एंड
सर्टिफिकेशंस की बात कर रहे हैं। तो हम
सर्टिफिकेशंस की ज्यादा बात नहीं करने
वाले हैं। क्योंकि मैं सर्टिफिकेशन पे
फोकस नहीं करने वाला हूं। बट यहां पे
टूल्स में एसआईएम प्लेटफॉर्म्स को हम
डिस्कस करेंगे देखेंगे। इडीआर एसडीआर
सॉलशंस हैं। थ्रेट एंड इंटेलिजेंस के
टूल्स हैं। एंड टिकेटिंग सिस्टम्स पे पहले
भी मैंने बता दिए। सर्टिफिकेशन में अगर आप
मतलब बाय चांस सोच रहे हैं ना करने का। तो
एंट्री लेवल में कॉम्पटिया सिक्योरिटी
प्लस जो है हैंडल कर लेती है इसको।
काइंड ऑफ उसके बाद ब्लू टीम लेवल वन का भी
सर्टिफिकेशन है। आप इसको भी
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं। देख सकते हैं।
सर्टिफाइड साइबर सिक्योरिटी डिफेंडर है।
इसको भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं। एंड टूल
स्पेसिफिक जो है तो स्प्लंक कोर सर्टिफाइड
यूजर Microsoft का SC 200 ये आता है जो कि
टूल स्पेसिफिक स्प्लंक एंड इसके लिए आते
हैं। तो इसको आप कर सकते हैं। अब मैं
सर्टिफिकेशन के इसलिए बता रहा हूं कि मैं
नहीं चाहता यार कि मैं एक तरफ बायस्ड हो
के आपको चीजें बताऊं कि नहीं भाई
मतलब
यह मत करो, वो मत करो। मैं आपको ऑप्शन
सारे दे देना चाहता हूं। आपके पास ऑप्शन
सारे होने चाहिए।
डिसीजन आपका होना चाहिए कि आपको क्या चूज़
करना है। इट्स इट शुड बी टोटली ऑफ योर्स
व्हाट यू हैव टू चूज़। क्या आपको कॉस्टली
सर्टिफिकेशंस करने हैं? अगर आपके पास पैसे
हैं तो बिल्कुल करिए। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
यह आपको फ्री रिसोर्सेज एंड इफ्रॉनिक्स की
एसओसी ट्रेनिंग करके ही अपनी स्किल्स को
उस लेवल पे लेकर जाना है जिस जितनी नॉलेज
और स्किल उस सर्टिफिकेशन वाले के पास भी
शायद शायद होगी या नहीं भी होगी पता नहीं
मुझे नहीं पता। हमारे तो ऐसे-से
स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो बड़े-बड़े टॉप
सर्टिफिकेशंस ओएसटीपी के सर्टिफिकेशंस
वाले के जितने नॉलेज है उससे ज्यादा
नॉलेजेस ले लेते हैं। डिफ्रॉनिक से पढ़ के
आप नहीं मानोगे। बट इट्स ट्रू। ठीक है?
हां। अब ये लास्ट स्लाइड है। इसके बाद हम
एक दूसरे से बातें करेंगे, इंटरेक्ट
करेंगे और सेशन को एंड करेंगे। योर पाथ
फॉरवर्ड फ्रॉम ट्रेनिंग टू एंप्लॉयमेंट।
नाउ यू हैव द कंप्लीट रोड मैप फ्रॉम
एब्सोल्यूट बिगिनर टू इंटरव्यू रेडी
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट एल1। द जर्नी रिक्वायर्स
एटलीस्ट थ्री मंथ्स ऑफ़ डेडिकेटेड लर्निंग।
एटलीस्ट थ्री मंथ्स। थोड़ा बहुत ऊपर नीचे
होगा। बट द करियर अपोरर्चुनिटीज़ आर
सब्सटेंशियल ग्लोबल डिमांड फॉर एसोसिस
एनालिस्ट फार एक्सीड सप्लाई विथ थाउजेंड्स
ऑफ़ अनफुलफिल्ड पोजीशंस अक्रॉस द
इंडस्ट्री। ये तो सच्ची बात है।
लेफ्ट्रोनिक्स इज़ ऑलवेज बेस्ट। सर भूख लगी
है। अरे मेरे को भी भूख लगी है यार भाई।
अरे वी लव योर जेन्युइन हेल्प सर। थैंक यू
ब्रदर। भूख मुझे भी लगी है। थोड़ा वेट कर
लो। 10 मिनट और रुक जाओ। 10 मिनट्स 10 से
15 मिनट मैक्सिमम रुक जाओ। जाके खा लेना।
मुझे भी भूख लगी है यार। मैं भी तो बैठा
हूं यहां पे।
ठीक है? थोड़ा थोड़ा और वेट कर लो। तो आपका
कुछ अप्रोच होना चाहिए। पहला बिल्ड योर
होम लैब। सेट अप वर्चुअल बॉक्स विद
सिक्योरिटी अनियन और वाजू फ्री एसआईएम आता
है। वजू जो है फ्री एसआईएम है। प्रैक्टिस
एनालिसिंग लॉस क्रिएटिंग अ लॉस
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग इंसिडेंस
हैंड्स ऑन एक्सपीरियंस ये सब चीजें आपको
करनी है। ये सब चीजें मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा।
तो मैं आपको बस ये ओवरव्यू दे रहा हूं।
सिखाऊंगा मैं आपको बताऊंगा। तो बेफिक्र
रहिए उसके लिए। डॉक्यूमेंट्स एवरीथिंग।
क्रिएट अ पोर्टफोलियो ऑन गीटब
डॉक्यूमेंटिंग योर इन्वेस्टिगेशंस। Lindin
पे भी आप डॉक्यूमेंट कर सकते हैं। एसआईएम
क्वरीज़ इंसिडेंट रिस्पों्स प्लेबुक्स। ये
सारी चीजें आपको करनी है। एंड थिंक लाइक अ
डिफेंडर। डिफेंडर की तरह थिंक करना है।
एवरीडे रीड सिक्योरिटी ब्लॉग्स, एनालाइज
रियल ब्रीचेस, आस्क योरसेल्फ हाउ वुड द
एसओसी हैव डिटेक्टेड दिस। डेवलप द
माइंडसेट बिफोर द जॉब इंटरव्यूअर्स
इंस्टेंटली रिकॉग्नाइज़ कैंडिडेट्स हु थिंक
ऑपरेशनली नॉट थ्योरेटिकली। जॉब इंटरव्यूअर
जो होते हैं ऑपरेशनली थिंकिंग वाले जो
लर्नर्स होते हैं उन्हीं को ज्यादा वैल्यू
देते हैं। थ्योरिटिकल वाले को सिर्फ
वैल्यू नहीं देते हैं। जो बस थ्योरी जानते
हैं। उसको प्रैक्टिकली इंप्लीमेंट करना
नहीं जानते।
अब सबसेेंट स्टेप जो मैंने पहले भी बता
दिया है जॉइन एसओसी एनालिस्ट WhatsApp
ग्रुप बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स जिसका लिंक वीडियो
के डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगा।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी फ्री WhatsApp चैनल
इसको फॉलो कीजिए। वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन
में लिंक मिल जाएगा। आफ्टर ईच क्लास मेक
की पॉइंट्स इन योर नोट्स एंड पोस्ट ऑन
Lindin एंड टैग डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। एंड हर वीडियो को जितना शेयर
कर सकते हो कीजिएगा। बस। अब एक चीज़ एक
छोटी सी पंच लाइन मार देता हूं आप सबके
लिए। आपको मजा आएगा। द बेस्ट एसओसी
एनालिस्ट आर नॉट वंस हु मेमोराइज एवरी
टूल। दे आर द वंस हु अंडरस्टैंड अटैकर्स
बिहेवियर। थिंक क्रिटिकली अंडर प्रेशर एंड
कम्युनिकेट फाइंडिंग्स क्लियरली। मास्टर द
थिंकिंग एंड द टूल्स बिकम सिंपल
इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स ऑफ योर एक्सपर्टीज।
यह एक पंच लाइन है जो मैंने आपके लिए मार
दी है। इससे आपको थोड़ा सा अंदर से जोश आ
जाएगा नेक्स्ट क्लासेस के लिए। नेक्स्ट
क्लासेस में भी ऐसे ही आना है। अगर आप
नहीं आओगे तो यह आपकी गलती है। क्योंकि जो
लाइव में सीख लोगे वो रिकॉर्डिंग के थ्रू
आप कभी नहीं कर पाओगे। मैं आपको गारंटी
देता हूं इसकी। सो वेलकम टू द ब्लू
टीमिंग। वेलकम टू द ब्लू टीम। योर जर्नी
टू प्रोटेक्टिंग ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस फ्रॉम
साइबर थ्रेट्स स्टार्ट्स नाउ विफ्रोनिक्स
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट फ्री लाइफ ट्रेनिंग एल
वन। दैट्स इट गाइस। शुरू करते हैं हमारी
हमारी ये एक्स्ट्राऑर्डिनरी
जर्नी एंड यू ऑल आर वेलकम टू इम्बार्क ऑन
अ ग्रेट जर्नी ऑफ बिकमिंग एन एसोसिएट लेवल
एल वन जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम आप
करने वाले हैं। तो यहां पे हमारी स्लाइड्स
की माया खत्म हो जाती है। फिलहाल हम इस
स्लाइड्स को बंद कर देते हैं। ये स्लाइड्स
अगर आपको चाहिए तो मुझे बता दीजिए।
WhatsApp ग्रुप जो आप जॉइ करे हैं वहीं पे
आपको मिल जाएगी यह स्लाइड। तो अगर आपको
चाहिए तो प्लीज बताइए। प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ
यू वांट दिस स्लाइड।
अगर नहीं चाहिए तो कोई बात नहीं है।
सबको चाहिए होगा मुझे पता है। कोई ऐसा तो
होगा नहीं जिसको नहीं चाहिए। अरे भाई बस
करो भाई।
इतना खतरनाक
इतनी खतरनाक चैट करोगे। चैट वो करोगे तो
कैसे चलेगा भाई?
तुम लोग जो चैटिंग कर रहे हो ना इतनी तेजी
से आ रही है
जो मैसेजेस हैं आपके कभी-कभी ऐसा लग रहा
है कि क्या हो रहा है चाहिए रिसोर्सेज
चाहिए जल्दी बताओ रिसोर्सेज चाहिए लेट मी
नो रिसोर्स डू यू नो द डू यू वांट द
रिसोर्सेज
तो WhatsApp ग्रुप जरूर ज्वाइन करना याद
रखिएगा जॉइ कर लोगे तो मजा आएगा राइट
हो ठीक है थैंक यू वेरी मच
चलिए
अब 5 मिनट पांच मिनट की बातें कर लेते हैं
एंड देन वी विल एंड दिस सेशन क्योंकि
ऑलरेडी काफी लंबा हो चुका है। जैसा कि
मैंने बोला था कि अगली सेशंस जो होंगी वो
आपकी थोड़ी शॉर्ट हुआ करेंगी। आज पहला
सेशन था। बहुत कुछ आपको बताना था। पूरा
ओवरव्यू देना था। तो हम थोड़ा यहां पे
लेंथ हमने बढ़ाया। ट्राईक मी का काफी रोल
होने वाला है आपके इस पूरे ट्रेनिंग में।
काफी कुछ हम समझने वाले हैं। तो एक-एक चीज
हम करेंगे।
ओके। सो गाइस सबसे पहले कैसा लगा यह सेशन
आपको कितना मजा मजा आया नहीं आया बता
दीजिए हाउ वास द सेशन जोश में बताइए और
मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि इस सेशन
से आपने जो भी चीजें सीखी हैं आज जिस इस
सेशन से जो भी चीजें आज आपको मैंने सिखाया
थोड़ी भी चीजें कुछ सीखी होंगी ना तो आई
वुड रिक्वेस्ट कि आप प्लीज Lindin पे
जाइएगा। Lindin पे आप एक नया पोस्ट
स्टार्ट कीजिएगा। इस पोस्ट में जो है सारी
चीजें डॉक्यूमेंट कीजिएगा। की पॉइंट्स की
तरह लिखिएगा। एंड फिर लास्ट में हमें @
dfonics ऐसे सर्च करके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एंड फिर @ नितेश सर्च करेंगे
या टेक्निकल नेविगेटर तो मुझे भी टैग कर
दीजिएगा एंड हमें भी ताकि पता चल जाए। तो
यह काम जरूर कीजिएगा। यह मैं आपको इसलिए
नहीं करवा रहा कि आप हमें टैग करें या
हमें पता चले। इसका आपकोेंस समझ में आएगा
जब आप डॉक्यूमेंट करना शुरू कर देंगे हर
दिन का जैसे डे वन की पॉइंट्स ऑफ एसओसी
लाइव ट्रेनिंग ऑन डेफोनिक्स एकडमी YouTube
चैनल दैट्स इट फिर पूरा आप की पॉइंट कर
दीजिए टैग कर दीजिए ये आपकी हेल्प करेगी
आपके ही स्किल्स को ग्रो करने में आपके
पास एक ना अनइंटेंडेड अनइटेंडेड नोट्स
क्रिएट हो जाएंगे जब आप ट्रेनिंग खत्म कर
लोगे ना तो Lindin पे ही आपके सारे नोट्स
रहेंगे। सोचो
मतलब आप एक-एक दिन का करोगे आपके आपके
नोट्स
तैयार हो जाएंगे और लोगों को भी पता
चलेगा। बाकी लोगों को भी समझ में आएगी। आप
चाहे तो इस प्लेलिस्ट की लिंक दे सकते
हैं। वीडियोस के लिंक दे सकते हैं। उन
पोस्ट्स में लोगों को बता सकते हैं। राइट?
ओके। व्हाई डिमांड फ्रेशर्स विद
एक्सपीरियंस? फ्रेशर्स को एक्सपीरियंस की
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। भाई फ्रेशर्स इसमें
आप आ सकते हैं। एज अ फ्रेशर आ सकते हैं।
ठीक है। आई थिंक ग्रुप में काफी लोग जुड़
गए होंगे अभी तक। मुझे लगता है ग्रुप फुल
ना हो गया हो यार। मैं एक बार चेक कर लेता
हूं कि ग्रुप में कितने लोग आ चुके हैं
क्योंकि एक ग्रुप तो ऑलरेडी फुल हो चुकी
थी कल। फर्स्ट ग्रुप ऑलरेडी फुल हो चुका
था। सेकंड ग्रुप हमने बना दी थी एंड मुझे
लगता है कि उसमें भी काफी लोग आ गए होंगे।
मुझे डाउट है। ओह माय गॉड। 257 पीपल हैव
जॉइ सेकंड ग्रुप में। पहला 1024 पीपल हैव
ऑलरेडी जॉइ फर्स्ट ग्रुप। सेकंड ग्रुप को
257 लोगों ने ज्वाइन कर लिया है और आपको
अगर नहीं पता तो ग्रुप का लिंक वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगी। आप उससे जॉइ
कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? डायरेक्ट लिंक मैं
यहां पे नहीं दे रहा हूं। फॉर सम रीज़ सो
यू कैन जॉइन द ग्रुप। राइट?
हम आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगी। चलिए यहां पे
कुछ बातें कर लेते हैं। देन वी विल एंड
ओके विदाउट सर्टिफिकेट कंपनी हायर करेंगे।
अरे स्किल्स होने चाहिए। अगर इंटरव्यू तक
पहुंच जाते हो तो आपकी वो स्किल काम आएगी
एंड दे विल हायर यू। बस सिंपली इतना ही
मुझे पता है।
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी का भी होगा। बिल्कुल
होगा। बाय।
फ्रेशर्स की जॉब लगती है भाई एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एनालिस्ट एल1 में भी फ्रेशर्स की
जॉब लगती है। बिलीव मी काफी सारे मेरे
जानकार हैं जो एल1 रोल के लिए जॉब करते
हैं। फ्रेशर्स के तौर पे गए थे। सैलरी कम
थी उनकी। बाद में एक साल के बाद अच्छी
खासी ह उनको मिली है। सो या
ओके चलिए सर्टिफिकेशन
सब सर्टिफिकेशंस के रिगार्डिंग जो डिटेल
है ना वो आपको बताई जाएगी। उसके लिए आप
बेफिक्र रहिए। वो आपको हम बताएंगे। वह
आपको विल नोटिफाई यू ग्रुप के अंदर ही
आपको उसकी डिटेल आएगी।
सर माय टीम इज यूजिंग आईबीएम क्यू रेडर वी
डोंट हैव स्प्लंक। ठीक है कोई बात नहीं।
माय रोल इज़ अ वीए मैनेजमेंट बट आई
समटाइम्स हैव टू रिस्पांस टू द इंसिडेंस
रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम एसओसी। ओके। सो दिस विल
हेल्प मी अ लॉट। या यस मनीष आई होप कि ये
आपको काफी ज्यादा हेल्प करेगी। डेफिनेटली
इट विल हेल्प यू शोरली।
चलिए अब मैं यहां पे देख लेता हूं कितने
लोग आ गए यहां पे।
ओके बिल्कुल। ओके गुड नाइट। गुड नाइट।
ओके रिज्यूे बिल्डिंग ठीक है ऐड कर देंगे
ऐड कर देंगे कोई बात नहीं ऐड करेंगे
रिज्यूे बिल्डिंग भी ऐड कर देंगे नो इशज़
सर आई हैव सीएनएसपी सर्टिफाइड नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी प्रैक्टिशनर बाय द डैश डैश
ग्रुप इज इट गुड फॉर एसओसी वन अ मुझे नहीं
लगता कि अह अह मैं इस पे कमेंट करना
चाहूंगा अगर आपको लगता है कि उसमें के
टॉपिक्स आपको एक परफेक्ट एसओसीएल वन बनाते
हैं तो बिल्कुल ठीक है। अदरवाइज आप इस
पूरी ट्रेनिंग को कवर अप कर सकते हैं। इस
पूरी ट्रेनिंग को अटेंड कर सकते हैं। एंड
डेफिनेटली इट विल हेल्प यू।
ठीक है। वन ऑवर की कंटेंट लेने की कोशिश
करेंगे। ठीक है। सर सुपर 40 में आ गया हूं
मैं। क्या बात है। क्या बात है शाहिल?
ग्रेट।
सर एक अटेंडेंस फीचर और ऐड कर लो। कैसे
अटेंडेंस फ़चर को आता ही नहीं है शायद यहां
पे। आई डोंट थिंक कि यहां पे अटेंडेंस फ़चर
है YouTube के अंदर में। अभी आप लोग
WhatsApp ग्रुप में एक्टिव रहिएगा। वहां
पे आपको काफी कुछ अ
अपडेट्स मिलेंगे।
स्लाइड्स दे देंगे। ठीक है। ओके। वी विल
गिव यू द स्लाइड्स।
जो खान सर हैं पटना वाले जो कम प्राइस में
प्रिपरेशन करवाते हैं यूपीएससी की वैसे ही
आप सर इस फील्ड में खान सर हो अरे क्या
बात है आपने एक लेजेंड से कंपैरिजन कर
दिया इट्स
दैट्स ऑल इतना ही काफी है एक लेजेंड से
कंपैरिजन कर दिया आपने इससे बड़ी बात क्या
हो सकती है आई एम ग्रेसफुली एक्सेप्टिंग
दैट एंड आई एम ग्लैड कि आप ऐसा सोचते
विल एआई टेक ओवर जॉब्स? ना भाई कुछ नहीं
लेगा।
एसओसी में हां जी एसओसी में एआई इंटीग्रेट
कर सकते हैं। हालांकि अब जितने भी
प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं ऑलरेडी एआई को इंटीग्रेट
कर चुकी हैं। जो टूल सेट्स हैं। तो एआई
बेस्ड अलर्ट्स भी आ रहे हैं। सो यस दिस इज़
एआई इज़ ऑलरेडी इंप्लीमेंटेड। एआई को
ऑलरेडी इंप्लीमेंट कर चुका कर कर दिया गया
है। सो बेफिक्र रहिए उसके लिए। चलिए ठीक
है गाइस। आई होप आई इंटरेक्टेड विद यू ऑल।
आई होप कि आपको
ये सेशन जो है काफी मजेदार लगा होगा। ये
क्या हो गया भाई? इतनी छोटी कैसे हो गई
ये? चलिए।
ओके। सो नाउ
यह इतनी छोटी कैसे हो गई है यह लाइव नहीं
है क्या यह लाइव आ जाओ भाई यहां से लाइव
कर लेते हैं या सो नाउ इट्स टाइम टू से
गुड बाय फॉर टुडे आज के लिए बस इतना ही
एंड थैंक यू एवरीबॉडी थैंक यू वेरी मच आप
सब ने इतना ज्यादा यहां पे प्रेजेंस दिखा
के इतनी ज्यादा अटेंडेंस दिखा के मजा मजा
आ गया मतलब एंड मुझे ऐसा उम्मीद है कि आप
अपने प्रॉमिस को फुलफिल करेंगे एंड आप ऐसे
ही लाइव अटेंड करेंगे। एंड जैसा कि मैंने
पहले बोला था आप सभी को कि WhatsApp ग्रुप
जरूर ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा जिसका लिंक वीडियो
के डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको इसी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी मिल जाएगा।
अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी
मिल जाएगा। एंड वहीं पे आपको सारी अपडेट्स
हैं जो भी चीजें हैं वो सब मिलेंगी। साथ
में हमारे सोशल हैंडल्स ये सारे आपको पता
है ही। आप इन पे हमें फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
हमसे मेरे साथ जुड़ सकते हैं। Lindin पे
भी आप मेरे साथ आके यहां पे जुड़ सकते
हैं। एंड दैट्स इट। तो यहां पे काफी लोगों
के नेटवर्क कने कनेक्शंस रिक्वेस्ट भी आ
चुकी है। वेल आई विल एक्सेप्ट दोज़
कनेक्शंस रिक्वेस्ट। ठीक है? सो दैट्स ऑल
गाइस। एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में
बहुत जल्दी ही एंड कुछ धमाका करते हैं।
स्टार्ट करते हैं एक अलग ही तरह की हमारी
इंटरेस्टिंग जर्नी को एंड आपको बनाते हैं
एसओसी लेवल वन एनालिस्ट। एसओसी एल वन
एनालिस्ट बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट। कोई पैसा
नहीं देना है। एंड जॉब रेडी बनके आप
निकलेंगे इस कोर्स के बाद। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। कीप सपोर्टिंग। शेयर कर दीजिए। अब
आपका यही काम बस मेरे को मेरे को बस चाहिए
एक आपसे सपोर्ट चाहिए कि आप वीडियोस को
शेयर कीजिए एंड जाते टाइम लाइक ठोकते हुए
जाइए। दैट्स इट। WhatsApp ग्रुप को ज्वाइन
कर लीजिए। WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर
लीजिए। थैंक यू गाइस। एंड
ठीक है। अटेंडेंस का अटेंडेंस का Google
फॉर्म अगर आप चाहते हैं कि अटेंडेंस का तो
बिल्कुल अगर आप लोगों ने अगर आप लोग
अटेंडेंस के लिए चाहते हैं तो मैं कोशिश
करता हूं Google फॉर्म आपको देने की
WhatsApp ग्रुप में ही दूंगा मैं आपको।
ठीक है? तो आप ऑनेस्टली बताइएगा WhatsApp
ग्रुप में। अगली बार से क्या होगा कि यहां
लाइव सेशन में भी मैं आपको दे दूंगा। बट
अगर बाय चांस ना दे पाए तो आपको WhatsApp
ग्रुप में वो अटेंडेंस का जो रजिस्टर है
वो आपको दे दिया जाएगा एंड आप जो है वहां
पे अटेंडेंस के थ्रू बता सकते हैं कि आपने
अटेंड करी है क्लासेस है हमें भी थोड़ा
आईडिया लग जाएगा एंड आगे सर्टिफिकेशन में
हेल्प करेगी ठीक है जो सबसे ज्यादा एक्टिव
रहेंगे अ उनको काफी हेल्प मिलेगी
सर्टिफिकेशन में मैं आपको इतना ही हिंट
दूंगा अभी ठीक है थैंक यू वेरी मच चलिए
बक बाउंड्री की सीरीज की भी वीडियोस आएंगी
अभी आएंगी आएंगी टेंशन फ्री रहिए आप उसकी
भी आएंगी। ठीक है? तो दैट्स ऑल गाइस। थैंक
यू सो मच। लाइक ठोक दीजिए, शेयर कर दीजिए
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बहुत
जल्दी ही। एंड स्टार्ट करते हैं धमाकेदार
हमारी इस लर्निंग जर्नी को। थैंक्स। बाय।